Hörst du mich, Mick?
Ganz geil.
Offensichtlich hört Jörg mich jetzt nicht mehr.
Nee.
Hörst du noch was, Mick?
Hörst du nichts mehr?
Oh Gott.
Ja.
Hörst du jetzt was? Hallo?
Ah, okay.
Da ist was.
Jetzt ist unser Studio-Link-Aplink ab und zu mal defekt.
Das heißt, ich lass einfach das Ding mal an.
das kann passieren, dass du uns ein bisschen gedoppelt hörst.
Na, das kann ja nur positiv
werden.
Ja, hi Kilian.
Hey Henrik.
Hi Schmidtlauch.
Hi ihr beiden.
Und hi am anderen Ende dieser Leitung.
Hi Mick.
Sollen wir dich eigentlich Mick nennen?
Mit den Namen ist das gerade ein bisschen kompliziert.
den Herrn Schmidtlauch, nennen wir weiter den Herrn Schmidtlauch, das ist für den
Herrn Schmidtlauch vollkommen in Ordnung.
Der Schmidtlauch stimmt zu. Schmidtlauch passt.
Mick, du kannst
mit Mick adressiert werden, das ist
der, widerstrebt dir nicht?
Ja, das bin ich gewohnt.
Ich glaube, da hätte er sich einen anderen Nick ausgesucht,
für den das widerstreben würde.
Okay, cool. Also,
wir hoffen einfach mal, dass das mit dem Ton klappt.
Das ist Akronomisierbar
Folge 37.
Ja, und mit Abstand die technisch
komplizierteste bisher.
Und das ist auch die erste Folge mit Remote-Anteilen.
Sagt derjenige, der mit der
Stimme sitzt.
Ja, man sollte ja eigentlich denken, dass sowas wie
Voice-Over-IP ein mittlerweile gelöstes Problem
ist, aber man kann auch immer wieder feststellen, dass es
gar nicht mal so untrivial ist.
Gar nicht mal so trivial ist.
Also wir hoffen einfach mal, dass hier gerade nicht alle paar Sekunden
still sind in der Aufnahme,
dass ihr als Hörer auch wirklich alle hören könnt.
Es sollten vier Leute im Gespräch sein.
Ja, wenn nicht, dann machen wir
einfach einen kurzen Trip nach
nach Schottland und dann machen wir es einfach lokal
beim Mix zu Hause. Das geht wahrscheinlich
auch. Wir haben uns ja heute
zusammengefunden, um ein wenig
über Nix zu reden.
Nicht als ob wir nicht schon die ganze Zeit über Nix
reden, aber das
wird das Sonderthema dieser
Folge akronomisierbar sein.
Und deswegen
würde mich jetzt mal interessieren,
wieso seid ihr beide eigentlich Kandidaten,
die über Nix redet?
Vielleicht könntet ihr euch mal ganz kurz vorstellen,
Fangen wir mit dem Herrn Schmittler auch, der hier direkt neben uns sitzt, an.
Ja, also ich benutze sehr gerne irgendwelche obskuren Systeme.
Also dadurch war ich wahrscheinlich schon mal etwas anfälliger dafür.
Also beispielsweise benutze ich irgendwie auf meinem Smartphone statt Android ein Selfish OS.
Habe lange Jahre Gentoo benutzt.
Davor auch mal Arch Linux, was mir dann aber irgendwann zu stressig war, weshalb ich zu Gentoo gewechselt bin.
Versteht.
Aber irgendwann hat mir halt das ganze Kompilieren in Gen 2 dann doch zu lange gedauert.
Ist auch schlecht für die Umwelt.
Und dann habe ich Mick mal im C3D2 getroffen.
Und der hat mich dann halt eben einmal anevangelisiert, was Nixos angeht.
Angenix, hat er wieder gesagt.
Ja, der hat auf jeden Fall ordentlich Werbung für Nixos gemacht.
Und ja, dann war ich irgendwann so genervt und hatte mal eine Woche lang Zeit.
Und dann habe ich einfach mal Nixers installiert und benutze das jetzt seit über einem Jahr.
Erfolgreich angenext. Und jetzt bist du eine Koryphäe auf dem Gebiet von Nix?
Nicht wirklich Koryphäe.
Also einerseits kann man sagen, ja, ich benutze jetzt seit knapp einem Jahr.
Wahrscheinlich bin ich ein bisschen tiefer drin als irgendwie so ein Standardnutzer,
weil ich eben einfach die Software, die mir gefehlt hat,
selbst paketit habe.
Und
irgendwie halt
in Kreisen rumhänge, die eben sehr gerne
über nichts reden.
Ja, aber so richtig...
Ich glaube, ich kann da immer noch
einen etwas oberflächlicheren
Einblick aus einer anderen Perspektive
bieten als Mick.
Und
Mick, wer bist du
und wie bist du zu Nix gekommen?
So.
Ich bin gerade in Schottland,
mache da mein PhD an der
University of Edinburgh
und ich bin
in den Mixstopf gefallen
vor drei bis vier Jahren.
Ich hatte eigentlich nur irgendwie
mich hat es einfach genervt,
wie Docker-Container gebaut werden,
dass auf einen Haufen Speicherplatz
verschwendet wird und so weiter.
Da habe ich mich nach Alternativen umgeschaut
und da habe ich dann so ein Projekt gefunden,
was halt
Nix benutzt
damit dann
Container baut und
habe an der vier Speicherplatz
schon eine Variante, weil
nicht immer jedes Mal alle Pakete neu
reinkopiert wurden, sondern einfach
vom Ost sich
rübergezogen wurden.
Und ja, dann habe ich dann halt irgendwann angefangen,
wollte ich halt damit dann diese Containerlösung,
eine neue Containerlösung bauen und
bin dann aber irgendwann dazu
zum Punkt gekommen, wo ich dann einfach gesagt habe, okay,
ich brauche eigentlich dieses ganze Containerkram
überhaupt nicht, sondern wird es einfach nichts mehr auf meinem System.
Und
hab dann irgendwann angefangen,
ja, so Pakete,
die noch nie
verfanden waren, mit
Snix-Packages hinzuzufügen,
was dieses Repo ist.
Und ja, hab dann
vor dreieinhalb Jahren
Commit-Rechte bekommen,
hab dann ziemlich viele
Pull-Requests auf
die in das Pack geschickt wurden,
gemerged und
bin jetzt derzeit auch in so einem
FCC-Committee,
wo sich damit beschäftigt werden,
wo Leute irgendwie größere Endungen,
die nichts gemacht werden,
die Erfolg geschlagen werden,
diesen Prozess da zu betreuen
und ja,
das tut es eigentlich nichts überall.
Das funktioniert gut für mich.
Cool.
Was wir noch nicht dazu gesagt haben,
ist, dass wir dich ja eigentlich auch schon
seit geraumer Zeit mittlerweile kennen,
weil du auch ein alter Ascianer bist.
Also unsere Gäste
beziehen wir
doch immer noch recht zuverlässig
aus den alten Asci-Kreisen.
Ja, finde ich sehr gut.
Gut, dann gehen wir doch langsam mal
ins Thema rein.
Ja, da gibt es nichts zu erzählen.
Und bevor wir jetzt
die Wortwitze noch weiter
strapazieren, ich finde, das ist
irgendwann, das ist einfach nichts lustig.
sollten wir vielleicht langsam mal ins Thema reinkommen
und uns mal erzählen, warum,
wir reden ja schon eine Weile drüber, dass wir mal über nix reden
wollten, aber was zum Geier ist nix
überhaupt?
Kann mir einer von den anwesenden Gästen
das eventuell so, also ich
muss wirklich sagen, ich habe mich gar nicht vorbereitet,
könnt ihr mir das irgendwie in drei Sätzen
kurz zusammenfassen, was nix überhaupt
ist? Ich denke mal, das ist ein Paketmanager, andere
sagen, das ist eine Linux-Distribution, was ist das nur eigentlich?
Nix ist ein Paketmanager, so ein System-Paketmanager
auf so einer Art
in der Ebene wie
Upt oder
Homebrew.
Aber es hat ein bisschen ein anderes
Konzept, und zwar wie es
mit Paketen umgeht und mit Abhängigkeiten
und so weiter.
Und, ja.
Ja, vor allem der Hauptunterschied
ist einerseits, dass
er eben Pakete
also was einem als erstes auffallen
wird, ist, dass er eben Pakete nicht immer
an dieser Bestelle installiert, obwohl es eigentlich das gleiche
Paket ist, sondern je nachdem,
welche Version des Paketes ist, sie letztendlich
an anderen Stellen landen. Und
das sorgt eben dafür, dass man
dann als Nutzer so schöne
Vorteile hat, dass man einfach auf
die letzte Version zurückrollen
kann und dass zwischendurch
eigentlich Dinge nicht kaputt gehen.
Also vollwertig durchversioniert. Ich habe
alle Versionen da und kann da komplett
durchtwitchen, wie ich lustig bin. Genau, denn
sobald sich irgendwas beim Bauen
eines Pakets ändert, wird das Paket einfach an eine andere
Stelle gebaut. Und wenn
fertig gebaut ist, dann
switcht man einfach atomat rüber.
Und das, also ich weiß nicht,
ihr beide sitzt ja jetzt ja
irgendwie mit MacBooks, aber
ich gehe mal davon aus, dass ihr
irgendwie auch schon irgendwelche kruden
Arch-Linux-Erfahrungen oder sowas habt.
Ja genau, also wenn ich das mal vergleichen würde,
ich bin ja eigentlich so
Linux-versiert nicht unbedingt. Ich benutze
jetzt seit zehn Jahren Arch-Linux, weil es relativ
einfach ist.
Und da ist es einfach so, dass der Paketmanager Pac-Man, auch ein sehr schöner Paketmanager, das ist einfach bloß eine Beschreibung für die Pakete, wie sie zu bauen sind.
Und dann baut er in einem virtuellen Root-Verzeichnis die Pakete so zusammen, dass alle Dateien in der Struktur, in der sie dann in mein System kopiert werden sollen, da liegen.
Und dann nimmt er sie und kopiert sie in mein System.
Das Problem ist, du hast gerade schon im Plural gesprochen, dann nimmt er sie.
Das Problem ist nämlich meistens, also bei Arch bin ich mir jetzt nicht hundertprozentig sicher,
aber ich kann es mir eigentlich nicht anders vorstellen, ist,
dass er einfach, sobald er irgendein Paket fertig gebaut hat,
es dann auch installiert und eben an die Stelle userlib, lib64, libpng.so oder sowas liegt.
Das ist halt quasi eine Ordnerstruktur von was in meinem User und was in meinem Lib
und was in meinem BIN-Verzeichnis zu liegen hat und in meinem ETC-Verzeichnis.
Genau.
Das rollt er dann so aus.
Er merkt sich dann irgendwie, was er wohin kopiert hat, dass er es auch wieder deinstallieren kann.
Erstes Problem aber ist halt schon mal, das passiert Stück für Stück.
Und eben wenn wir irgendwann ein Programm bauen,
was zum Beispiel gegen die LibPNG oder was irgendwelche Hader von der LibPNG und sowas braucht,
dann kann das natürlich erst nach der LibPNG zum Beispiel gebaut werden.
Und die LibPNG wird eben auch schon vorher installiert auf dein System,
damit eben der Build-Prozess eben die nötigen Files findet.
Und wenn dann aber irgendwie der Build-Prozess irgendwie zwischendurch fehlschlägt,
dann hast du eben einen inkonsistenten Stand rumzuliegen,
weil einfach jedes System einzeln,
jedes Paket einzeln schon installiert wurde
und das vorherige Paket im Zweifel sogar überschrieben hat.
Und du dann im Zweifel, wenn irgendwas kaputt geht,
ein kaputtes System hast.
Also das ist jetzt eine Annahme,
aber mein inkonsistenter Stand heißt,
ich habe für mein Paket,
also ich installiere Firefox oder so,
habe ich drei Abhängigkeiten installiert
und habe dann den Rest nicht installiert,
aber es ist nicht so,
dass ich inkonsistente Pakete installiere,
Ja, aber was zum Beispiel...
Du hast den LibPNG schon überschrieben.
Er überschreibt ja nicht die Sachen,
die bereits...
Wenn es passiert,
dass ein Paket die gleiche Datei
schreiben möchte wie ein anderes Paket,
dann gibt es eigentlich bei Pac-Man bereits einen Fehler.
Nur wenn es unterschiedliche Pakete sind.
Wenn ich mein Firefox
update,
dann ist ja der neue Firefox auch wieder unter
Userbin Firefox zu finden.
Du kannst nicht zwei Versionen vom gleichen Paket installiert haben.
Das ist das, was jetzt nichts anders macht.
Die legen quasi
einen Unterordner für jedes einzelne Ding an.
Genau.
Es geht um zwei verschiedene Probleme.
Einmal, dass irgendwie
der Installations- oder Upgrade-Vorgang
gar nicht komplett durchläuft, sondern einfach
zwischendurch abbricht.
Ich habe das durchaus schon gehabt,
dass ich unter Arch,
mir das irgendwie zwei, dreimal passiert,
dass es abgegradet hat.
Und in dem Moment ist irgendwas Komisches passiert,
als er gerade versucht hat, die LibC
abzudritten und dann hat man dann ein System
ohne LibC. Das ist dann sehr
spaßig, weil alle Programme
irgendwie die LibC verwenden. Dann muss man
sich dann irgendwie wieder einen USB-Stick
irgendwo anders zusammenfremeln, das
in seinen Rechner stecken, dann davon
booten, sich in das System rein
change-routen und das dann wieder
repräsentieren. Also, das
passiert durchaus. Genau. Und das zweite Szenario
ist,
ich habe halt auch vor NixOS
mal irgendwie Gentoo benutzt und da dauert
Systemupdate schon mal etwas länger,
wenn irgendwie so ein Firefox mal anderthalb Stunden vor sich hin baut.
Und dann kann es eben passieren, dass eben schon die
Library upgedatet wurde,
für die irgendein Programm dann braucht.
Und dann will ich aber immer noch
parallel auf dem System weiterarbeiten,
starte ein Programm und das wirft mir halt
ein linker Error entgegen, weil eben die
Library, gegen die es gerne
linken würde, nicht mehr da ist und
die nicht mehr
binary-kompatibel ist, die neue Version.
Also Gento zu verwenden ist
heutzutage auch grundlegend
normalisch fragen würde.
Ich hab Gentoo genutzt, weil mir Arsch zu stressig war.
Was?
Ich meine, allein wegen der Kompilierzeit,
das Logo ist ein Pinguin und die Pinguine sterben,
weil wir alle die ganze Zeit unsere Firefox neu
kompilieren.
Nee, aber, ja, ich frage mich
dann gerade, wie konnte das passieren,
dass du, aber das ist wahrscheinlich
alles eine valide Kritik,
ich frage mich nur, das heißt, du hast
dann bei deinem Gentoo,
wenn du ein Set mit 5
Dependencies gebaut hast, hast du die ersten
und sie ist bereits installiert, bevor du
angefangen hast, das letzte
Hauptpaket wirklich zu kompilieren.
Genau.
Aber das klingt ja, als könnte man das trivial lösen,
indem man einfach sagt, ich kompiliere erst alles und installiere
das dann in einer Art und Weise. Letztendlich ist das
aber eigentlich auch bei allen anderen Paketmanagern auch
genauso. Der Unterschied ist bloß, dass du meistens selbst
lokal nicht baust und deshalb auch nicht
irgendwo dagegen baust, sondern du
einfach eben nur dann Binary Packages
bekommst, wenn sie schon erfolgreich gebaut
sind. Das heißt, letztendlich hat eigentlich nur der Build-Server
das Problem. Genau. Und
Bei den einfacheren Distributionen, den Debian-basierten zum Beispiel, ist es so, dass zum Beispiel sowas wie Compiler-Versionen nur mit großen Distributionsversionen geupdatet werden, damit auch ja immer alles schön ABI-kompatibel bleibt miteinander.
Okay, also wir haben also dieses gemeinsame Problem beschrieben und das löst jetzt nichts, indem es was genau macht.
Also nix verabschiedet sich jetzt erstmal komplett eben von dem Konzept, dass es eben so eine Art globalen Search Path gibt, wo, wenn irgendein Programm braucht, jetzt die LPNG, weil das ist irgendwie das, was mit der Art schon mal kaputt gegangen ist, deshalb benutze ich das jetzt als Beispiel.
Und dann guckt eben der Linker oder auch der, ja, es ist eigentlich immer der Linker, dann eben in einem bestimmten Directory, was eben der LD-Library-Path oder sowas ist, nach, ob er dort eben einen Pfeil findet, was die PNG bereitstellt. Und diese globalen Search-Paths gibt es unter Nixer schon mal nicht.
Also mein Path ist einfach, die Path-Variable gibt es einfach nicht.
Genau, sondern es wird explizit, ja, es gibt nicht wirklich so einen Search-Path, wo einfach geguckt wird, was da jetzt drin ist, zumindest konzeptionell, wie es implementiert ist, ist nochmal ein bisschen anders,
sondern es wird quasi einfach immer explizit nur diese Library,
und zwar exakt diese Library als direkt absoluter Path,
mit in den Bauprozess und Startprozess mitgegeben.
Das heißt, es wird aber trotzdem noch dynamisch gelinkt?
Ja.
Aber Nix verwendet quasi dieses LD-Prelode anders,
und zwar für jedes Binary-Eigen.
Genau, und zwar, wenn man sich so ein Binary anschaut,
also gibt es hier so Binary-Formate unter
macOS
sind es irgendwie
die
die Y-Lip-Dinger
wie sind die?
Jedenfalls, hier haben die
Dylip, ja
und
Dylip, genau
und unter
Linux oder FreeBSD
sind das die 11 Binarys
oder
man hat diese.so-Dateien, also diese Shared Objects
was dann in der Menschen-Library sind
wenn man jetzt so eine Binary benutzt
zum Beispiel
Firefox, dann hat
Firefox das Binary,
setzt selber oder in dem
Executable von Firefox
ist sowas gesetzt, das nennt sich
AirPath und das ist einfach eine
Suchfahrt, was nur für das Executable
funktioniert. Das heißt, wenn Firefox
ist quasi an sich selbst content, ist das nie
von der Umgebung abhängig, sondern es ist quasi
isoliert und benutzt dann aber halt
eher Libraries,
die dann andere Programme, die sie selber
in Libraries verwenden, dann auch
verwenden würden.
Also wenn man jetzt mehrere
Programme hat, die zum Beispiel
ein NG bauen, dann würde
Firefox die gleiche
NG-Version verwenden wie jetzt ein anderes
Programm.
Genau.
Und das
Ganze...
Das war jetzt unter
Mac? Nee, unter Linux.
Nee, das war jetzt schon unter
nichts. Der grundlegende Unterschied
ist, also es ist
Tate ist in diesem Fall vielleicht ein bisschen missverständlich,
weil solange wir dynamisch linken,
braucht natürlich der Firefox auch noch
seine Libraries, die natürlich
einfach andere Files sind, aber im Unterschied
zu einer normalen Linux-Distro
oder einer macOS oder sowas,
ist es halt nicht so, dass, wenn das
Programm gestartet wird,
der
dynamische Linker durch
das Header vom Binary
geht und dort sieht, welche
Libraries so als Objekte
gebraucht werden und dann eben lostingelt
durch den Search-Path iteriert und guckt,
ob er da irgendwo eine passende Library mit passenden Symbolen findet
und sie dann reinlinkt,
sondern es steht schon direkt im Binary, was wir starten,
explizit als hardcoded absoluter Path drin,
wo jetzt eigentlich das File für die Libraries zu finden ist.
Und die Binary ist aber trotzdem von jemand anders gebaut worden?
Oder muss ich die lokal kompilieren?
Nein, das ist tatsächlich der Grund,
warum ich von Gen2 auf Nixis umgeschwenkt bin,
weil Nix ist eigentlich auch ein Source-Based Package Manager,
aber der Unterschied ist, es gibt sogenannte Binary Caches,
dass eben einfach ein Build-Server die Sachen vorbaut.
Das sind das Hydro-Dings?
Genau, das Hydro, da kommen wir vielleicht später noch zu.
Und dann kann man die sich einfach runterladen
und muss sie dann eben einfach in diesen passenden Pfad entpacken.
Denn diese Library, die jetzt beispielsweise Firefox zum Starten braucht,
da steht eben ja im Firefox ein bestimmter Pfad drin.
Und solange wir eben diese genauso
gebaute Library an exakt diesem Pfad anpacken,
funktioniert alles.
Das heißt, der Pfad leitet sich dann ab so von der
Version und ist quasi
wie so ein... Genau. Also
quasi
liegt die Library dann in einem
Pfad, wo in dem Pfad
der Hash aller Build-Inputs nochmal
drinsteht. Vielleicht das nochmal
genauer zu erklären. Also wenn man jetzt so ein
Paket baut,
dann gibt man da so eine
Datei an, die in dieser Sprache
geschrieben ist, die auch Nix heißt
oder Nix ist Fashion Language
und
was beim Bauen passiert, ist
dass Nix über alle
Abhängigkeiten, die das Programm hat
und über die Bauanleitung
ein Hash berechnet
und diesen Hash, der wir dann verwendet,
um dann den Installationspfad anzugeben
für das Paket. Also wenn ich jetzt
die LibPengen-Version ändere, dann würde
das in der Sprache dann halt eine andere Referenz sein,
die dann einen anderen Hash hat und dann würde
Da würde sich der Hash von der Firefox-Version
ebenfalls ändern und dann propagiert das quasi so
durch. Und dann wird das dann,
zum Beispiel bei Firefox würde das dann in
slash nix slash store, dann kommt so eine
Hash,
dieser Hash-Wert,
also in Hexer, die man das bringt, dann in minus,
dann Firefox und dann minus die Version.
Das ist dann so eine Art Konversion.
Und
ja, damit
kann man dann, sobald man halt
zum Beispiel irgendwas an Firefox oder
irgendeine Abhängigkeit von Firefox was ändert,
wird das halt neu gebaut
beziehungsweise ändert sich der Pfad und
damit
weiß dann nichts, dass
es den neu bauen muss oder beziehungsweise was es vorher
macht, es checkt halt, ob es schon ein Binary Cache
drin liegt. Das hat halt einen schönen Vorteil,
wenn jetzt irgendwie sich Pakete selber
anpasst, dann merkst du dann nichts, oh, das
habe ich, das Paket habe ich
jetzt noch gerade nicht installiert, du kannst vorher ein Binary Cache
gucken und wenn es da nicht da drin ist, dann
versuchst du es dann selber zu bauen. Also man hat
so das Beste von beiden Welten, man hat
halt sowohl ein Binary Cache,
wo man erstmal die meisten Programme
nicht selber bauen muss, aber dann, wenn man sobald
eine Anpassung machen will,
wird es dann Transparenz gebaut.
Abgefahren.
Ich versuche gerade mal das Thema ein bisschen zurück auf eure
Shownotes zu bringen.
Haben wir jetzt gerade den
Pfad eurer Planung
komplett verlassen, oder?
Das ist noch die Grundidee erstmal, was macht
nichts anders, also nichts Package Manager an der Stelle.
Ah, okay. Dann versuche ich das Thema
wieder aufzunehmen. Also, jetzt haben wir gerade besprochen,
es gibt nix den Paketmanager,
der in meinem System
Pakete
quasi
anhand ihrer Versionen installiert und
versucht möglichst nichts zu überschreiben dabei.
Und den kann ich aber auch auf diversen Systeme
einsetzen, da spricht ja nichts dagegen. Nix gibt es ja,
soweit ich weiß, auch für macOS, obwohl
die aktuelle Compatibility ein bisschen interessant ist
mit macOS Catalina, aber
da liegt daran, dass Apple das
System Volume jetzt auf eine extra Partition gelegt hat,
das read-only ist, aber
Mal abgesehen davon, ist Nix nicht abhängig davon,
was für eine Plattform drunter liegt.
Genau, du kannst Nix einfach auf quasi jede normale Linux-Distribution
oder eben auch ein macOS drauf installieren
und es bootstrappt dann halt alles, was benutzt,
von der Lib C bis nach oben selbst.
Also du brauchst natürlich schon ein bisschen mehr Speicherplatz.
Ich wollte gerade noch fragen, inwiefern explodiert denn das,
wenn du halt da alles komplett unabhängig voneinander...
Ist das irgendwas, was man im Moment erwarten muss?
Ich dachte, die Idee war,
dass du nicht alles komplett unabhängig voneinander installierst.
Also jetzt nur Speicherplatzbedarf-mäßig ist das wahrscheinlich kein großes Issue, aber...
Na, also du baust halt ein Library neu, sobald sich irgendwas quasi in den Inputs auch transient ändert.
Und insoweit hast du, also es ist auf jeden Fall Normalfall, spätestens wenn du irgendwie ein komplettes System-Update machst,
von einer Version zur anderen, hast du halt zumindest kurzzeitig quasi zweimal das System rumzuliegen.
Ja, okay, das hätte ich auch so erwartet.
Genau.
Die Sachen bleiben auch erstmal so lange liegen,
bis du sie eben weg-garbage-collectest.
Weil, genau,
es wird halt immer nur
was Neues geschrieben und dadurch kannst
du aber eigentlich auch immer noch jederzeit wieder quasi
ein Rollback machen. Eben so lange, bis du eben
die Dinge, die du nicht mehr brauchst, weg-garbage-collectest.
Das musst du aber explizit machen.
So, jetzt habt ihr gerade gesagt, man kann das quasi als
Package-Manager, also der fühlt sich ja jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon eher an wie der Package-Manager von so einer
Programmiersprache, anstatt eher wie der,
weil er halt nicht alles an eine Stelle
legt, sondern er hat für jeden Use-Case
sage ich, ich brauche Versionen davon oder ich brauche
Versionen so und so davon und Versionen so und so
davon und für dein Ziel, was du baust,
holt es sich dann seine Dependencies rein.
Und jetzt haben wir es gerade besprochen, man kann
es also offenbar auf anderen Betriebssystemen
installieren, aber es gibt auch noch NixOS
als Betriebssystem selber.
Ich hatte jetzt gerade überlegt, wenn ich Nix
benutzen möchte, muss ich mir dann auch NixOS installieren
oder jetzt kam gerade
der Punkt, der für mich interessant ist, ich
als Anfänger, der ich nur Arch Linux benutze,
könnte ich da also schon
anfangen, mir gewisse
jetzt also über Nix zu installieren,
parallel zu meinen Pac-Man
Dependencies auf meinem System.
Genau, das kannst du auf jeden Fall
problemlos tun, weil
der Unterschied zwischen Nix und NixOS
ist eben, dass bei NixOS
zusätzlich noch die Systemkonfiguration
eben genauso gebaut wird wie
eben sämtliche Software. Aber wenn es dir erstmal eben nur
um die Vorteile des Softwaremanagements geht,
dann kannst du das auch
ohne Probleme auf irgendeiner anderen Distro
verwenden und hast eigentlich auch die
komplette Funktionalität zumindest, was das
was eben das Softwarebauen
und Softwareverwalten angeht.
Und wie ist dann
der Einstieg?
Wenn ich jetzt eine Binary irgendwo...
Ja?
Mick?
Wir haben ja immer ein bisschen Delay,
da muss man Funkdisziplin waren. Also Mick, du bist dran.
Ja, und zwar
kenne ich ab und zu mal Leute, die
zum Beispiel auf irgendwelchen
guten Systemen arbeiten müssen,
zum Beispiel im High-Performance-Computing, wenn sie dann
irgendwelche alten Red-Ads oder CentOS-Installationen
vorgesetzt bekommen.
Und dann macht sich das dann gut, wenn man
irgendwie irgendwo sein X-Dar mit
reinschummeln kann.
Und dann einfach alle
Programme daraus installieren kann und dann
moderne Software verwenden kann.
Oder
ja,
man kann das
auch super einsetzen, um zum Beispiel
so Entwicklungsumgebungen
zusammenzustecken.
Man kann dann, wie ich so ein Projekt
so eine Datei schreiben, die heißt shell.nix
und dazu sind da zum Beispiel alle Abhängigkeiten,
die ich jetzt brauche, um genau dieses Projekt
zu bauen. Und
der Vorteil ist dann, dass man die
Programme nicht explizit installieren muss, sondern
halt nur für dieses Projekt installiert
und man kann sich das dann auch so
einrichten, dass man nur, wenn man dieses Projekt
betritt, also wenn man diese Shell
drin aufmacht, dass man
nur in dieser Shell jetzt diese projektspezifischen
Libraries und Programme
zur Verfügung hat und dass man jetzt
ein anderes Programm, äh andere
ein anderes Projekt hat, wo man zum Beispiel
die gleichen
Abhängigkeiten hat, aber die jetzt in anderen Versionen braucht,
aus irgendwelchen Gründen, dann kann man
die halt dann so in der
anderen Shell dort nichts so ausdrücken,
dass die dann sich nirgends gehegekommen
ist. Also man hat dann diese Dependency
hell, wenn man dann irgendwie
zwischen Projekten hin und her wechselt.
Das ist echt
ziemlich schick. Ist das die logische Weiterentwicklung
von dir end, was du mal
vor ein paar Jahren gezeigt hattest und was wir glaube ich
in der letzten Folge auch mit ange... in der vorletzten Folge
gepickt hatten.
Na, dir-end? Genau.
Ja, genau.
Einfach bloß die Umgebungsvariablen, aber das, was...
Und das...
Genau, dir-end hat in der Tat...
Ja, ganz kurz,
was du gerade beschrieben hast,
fühlt sich so ein bisschen an
wie Virtual-end für Python,
bloß halt auf Betriebssystem-Ebene.
Sodass ich sagen kann,
wenn ich dort bin, habe ich ein anderes WIM,
habe ich ein anderes Git.
Ja, ich meine, das ergänzt sich bloß prima miteinander gleich direkt,
die beiden Konzepte.
Ja.
Genau, und zwar hat Dianf in der Tat
Nix-Support.
Der Autor von Dianf
ist auch ein begeisterter Nix-User.
Ja, und das
mütze ich halt auch so zusammen.
Das heißt, man kann DIR-Enf benutzen, um für einen bestimmten Ordner eine bestimmte Nix-Shell zu starten?
Genau. Also DIR-Enf triggert dann eben einfach nur, dass quasi Nix im Hintergrund mal kurz angeschmissen wird,
dann im Zweifel die Pakete baut, wenn sie noch nicht gebaut sind oder irgendwie fetched
und sie dann eben den Path und sämtliche Umgebungsvariablen, über die das dann eben alles abläuft,
entsprechend modifiziert, dir diese Modifikation
zurückgibt und dann wird
das eben für diesen Ordner von dir
zu deinem Environment hinzugefügt.
Das Gute ist aber, sobald du eben wieder raus bist
oder eben in ein anderes Projekt reingehst,
liegen diese ganzen
Libraries und sowas immer noch irgendwo auf
deiner Platte, aber sie
haben halt für den aktuellen Zustand
des Systems keine Bedeutung mehr.
Das klingt ja fast so, als könnte
man das in CIs
so als Ersatz für Docker
verwenden, dass man sagt, ich brauche
die Version vom Compiler oder
die Version von dem Test-Framework
und dann sage ich einfach in meiner
CI hier diese Nix-Shell-Daten,
um meinen Code auszuführen. Machen das
Leute eventuell schon?
Ja, genau. Und zwar ist das so ein beliebter
Einstiegspunkt, um
das dann in seine Firma
reizuschubbeln quasi. Also hört man
häufig auf der NixCon,
dass diese Konferenz, die ehrlich stattfindet
über Nix, hört man auch gerne
Vorträge, wo dann jemand sagt,
und da habe ich mal
in die CI reingebaut und jetzt
müssen sie es alle benutzen können.
Und das hat dann halt auch,
es hat halt den Vorteil zum Beispiel
zu Docker, dass es nie diese
Containerisierung mit dem braucht, also man
manchmal stört das ja auch, wenn man
zu viel Isolation hat zwischen verschiedenen
Systemen, wenn man dann irgendwie
Shared-Mounts
oder Byte-Mounts dann
versucht, Daten auszutauschen und manchmal
weil wenn man einfach bloß mehrere Programme haben,
die miteinander funktionieren,
und ja, dann hat dieses Container-Konzept immer ganz viel Overhead.
Ja, ich sehe da gerade eine schöne Parallele eigentlich,
da sich ja Container wirklich viel mitbringen,
also nach dem Motto, ich muss das dorthin mounten,
und im Endeffekt lade ich so eine Lightweight Virtual Machine,
die aus verschiedenen Layers besteht, die aufeinander aufbauen,
Und bei Nix habe ich, wenn ich das richtig verstehe,
trotzdem irgendwie eine Dependency-Baumstruktur
oder so.
Aber es fühlt sich ja fast so ein bisschen an, als wäre
das so die Gegenüberstellung von
Composition over
Inheritance. Also der
Docker-Container ist so
das Inheritance-Modell.
Wenn ich mir ein System zusammenbaue mit
einer bestimmten Konfiguration, muss ich quasi ein Set
von Docker-Containern, die aufeinander geschichtet sind
und eigentlich nur
quasi als eine Dependency-Kette
aufeinander geschichtet werden können,
zusammenbauen und bei Nix kann ich
eher so ein bisschen Mix-on-Match-mäßig
mir was zusammenstecken
aus unterschiedlichen System-Dependencies.
Das wird flexibler auf jeden Fall.
Genau.
Ja, das wird doch...
Genau, also das
ist eigentlich ziemlich gut erkannt.
Man kann das, ja, es ist halt
Composable und man kann
in der Tat auch ziemlich gut
Docker-Container bauen mit Nix selber
und dann
sind diese Leer auch
composable. Und zwar, was dann nichts macht, ist
dann
diesen Docker-Bit-Commander,
also dieses Docker-File
da auszuführen und dann Leer für Leer
damit zu bauen, sondern was es
dann macht, ist, es baut selber quasi
es nimmt jedes
Paket, packt das in den Leer
rein und tut dann nur diese Leer zusammen
packen. Die werden dann
quasi von Docker gemountet.
Und das hat halt den Vorteil, dass
man die unabhängig von dann austauschen
kann, beziehungsweise
dass wenn man dann verschiedene Docker-Container hat,
dass sie dann auch die gleichen Layer wiederverwenden
würden, weil die einfach bloß
zwischen verschiedenen Paketen zum Beispiel
in einer anderen Reihenfolge geladen werden, aber das sind die gleichen
Images.
So was geht?
Wow, was? Moment, also
man baut sich Docker-Container auf
und die mounten sich dann trotzdem irgendwie
so im Nixpfade zusammen?
Ja.
Man hat dann quasi das
Image, was man baut und das referenziert dann einfach nur
diesen verschiedenen Layer und die sind dann aber
einfach nur umpaketierte Nix-Pakete im Prinzip.
Die werden einfach nur in dieses Docker-kompatible
Format geladen. Also gibt es dann zum Beispiel auch so
einen Webservice, das wurde
von jemandem, der bei Google arbeitet, gebaut.
Der hieß
Nixery.
Nixery, ah, genau.
Und dann kann man dann quasi dort eine URL...
Und hat ein Brokkoli als Logo.
Man kann da quasi einfach
Pakete angeben, die in Nix
drin vorkommen und dann baut der on the fly
so einen Docker-Container draus.
Also der hat dann so einen Web-Server,
der das dann lädt aus Nix-Packages.
Aber wozu brauche ich überhaupt noch
Docker?
Wenn du halt eine bestehende
Container-Infrastruktur hast. Also
manchmal ist halt nicht so einfach nix
jetzt irgendwie in alle Projekte
reinzuschleusen, insbesondere wenn du da jetzt irgendwie so
ein Kubernetes irgendwie rumzuhängen hast.
Also ich habe eine Infrastruktur, die
möchte einfach Docker-Container laden.
Genau, quasi der
Least Common Denominator,
was die Plattform im Frist, sind
Container-Images
und dann gibst du dem halt keine Binary, sondern eben
in Container-Image zerfackte Binarys.
Weil mehr Indirektion,
mehr gut.
Mind equals blown.
Ich mache das tatsächlich sehr gerne für meine Server-Infrastruktur,
weil ich damit zumindest eine
Basis habe, auf der ich gut weiß,
also zumindest mit einer Abstraktions-Ebene, mit der ich gut umgehen kann,
egal was für Software ich da
deploye, aber
das ist natürlich nicht die einzige gute Lösung,
aber zumindest kenne ich den Stack
und muss dann mich für ein anderes Paket nicht was komplett Neues überlegen.
Das wäre sicherlich
mit nichts genauso easy oder noch sauberer,
aber zumindest, wie gesagt,
kenne ich mich aus, was ich mache.
Ja, es gibt noch einen anderen Grund,
warum man zum Beispiel jetzt Docker verwenden will,
und zwar, wenn man irgendwie so eine
verteilte Infrastruktur hat mit Kubernetes
und so weiter, mit vielen Servern
und dann müssen die alle zusammen gelinkt werden
und irgendwie, dass da irgendwie
ein Service ausfällt, dass das woanders neu
deployed wird und sowas.
In dem Sinne gibt es zwar konventionell,
und zwar ist das Disnix,
das ist wahrscheinlich sogar älter als Kubernetes,
Aber ja, die Industrie hat sich halt dafür entschieden und das funktioniert halt auch ziemlich gut.
Und deswegen benutzen halt Leute in Firmen auch gerne Nix, um Docker-Container zu bauen,
um die dann mit Kubernetes auf ein größeres Cluster zu deployen.
Aber wenn es bloß zum Beispiel einen Server hat oder eine kleinere Anzahl von Servern hat,
dann funktioniert eigentlich Nix-Wise an sich auch schon ziemlich gut.
Man kann die dann auch von seinem Laptop aus schön deployen und nehmen einfach dieselbe Konfiguration, die man die ganze Zeit schon verwendet für NixOS, mit so einem Tool deployed, was Nixops heißt.
Und zwar, wir hatten ja vorhin schon angeschnitten, dass Nix an sich erstmal nur der Paketmanager ist und NixOS dazu die Systeme und Deeds und so weiter bereitstellt.
Und die Konfiguration, die man für Nix-OS schreibt,
dass die dann auch wieder von dem Paketmanager evaluiert und gebaut wird.
Also man beschreibt quasi seine komplette Systemkonfiguration mit dieser Nix-Programm-Sprache.
Das Ganze passiert in so einer Datei, die heißt etc.nix.os.configuration.nix.
Und darin kann man dann wirklich alles Mögliche definieren.
Also es gibt für die allermeisten Dienste gibt es da irgendwie schon so Module,
wo man dann sagen kann, ich würde mal gerne SSHD anstarten
und auf dem Port und jetzt noch meine Fiber-Konfiguration.
Das ist alles halt in so einer konsistenten Sprache, mit der man das ausdrückt.
Und wo man dann zum Beispiel, wenn man es irgendwie Dienstle konfiguriert,
dann eine Schnipsel hat, die man jetzt in irgendwelche verschiedenen Konfigurationen schreibt.
Dann hat man dann halt einen Befehl, um jetzt sein System upzudaten,
das heißt dann xs-rebuild und dann sagt man Sub-Command-Switch
und dann fängt er dann an, diese Konfiguration zu lesen,
die ganzen Konfigurationsdateien, die jetzt für die verschiedenen Programme benötigt werden, zu generieren
und das dann automatisch umzusetzen.
Also er tut dann auch die Dienste, die man jetzt definiert hat, die werden dann gestartet.
Und das ist eigentlich ganz nett.
Jetzt hast du gerade schon einen Haufen Tools erwähnt.
Vielleicht können wir das mal in eine übersichtliche Form bringen.
Also wir haben jetzt erwähnt, wir haben einen.
Ich würde gleich erst mal noch den, wir sind jetzt ja quasi von nichts zu nichts zu erst gegangen.
Die Tools und Best Practice würde ich vielleicht danach, nachdem wir die ganzen.
Ja genau, versuchen wir es mal ein bisschen zu sortieren.
Genau, was Mick jetzt gerade beschrieben hat, dass eben dann die ganzen Konfigurationsfiles für den SHD zum Beispiel gebaut werden und dann am besten noch die ganzen Dienste gestartet werden, denn Nix arbeitet da sehr stark mit Systemd, dass eben dann auch die ganzen Service-Files für Systemd gebaut werden und dann auch gestartet und neu gestartet werden.
Das ist eben jetzt dieser Übergang von Nix zu NixOS, dass eben zusätzlich zu den Paketen einzeln eben noch die gesamte Konfiguration, die Konfiguration für die Dienste und eben dieses ganze Instrumenting rundherum, also der Kernel selbst, die ganzen Services gebaut werden.
Und die werden letztendlich quasi von nichts genauso behandelt wie einfach irgendwelche anderen Pakete. Das heißt, sie landen eben auch, sobald man was ändert, woanders wieder. Das heißt, man kann, und das allerbeste ist eben, dass dann damit quasi im Gegensatz zu Dingen wie, verdammt, wie heißt nochmal dieses Python?
Virtual Env?
Nee, egal.
Fällt mir bestimmt ein.
Das im Gegensatz
zu anderen Software-Management-Plattformen
wie beispielsweise Chef oder sowas,
eben die
Systemkonfiguration
direkt eine Einheit
bildet mit der Software selbst.
Das heißt, wenn du die Software zurückrollst,
rollst du auch die Konfiguration zurück und umgekehrt.
Genau, was ich jetzt eigentlich
meint es eben dieses komische andere Python-Tool, was...
Ansible? Genau, Ansible.
Und dazu könnte ich jetzt
meine kurze Anekdote erzählen, und zwar
auf dem letzten Kongress
wurden dann, wurden
dummerweise alle
Talks mit Alpha
oder Pre-Alpha-Software aufgenommen
und geschnitten. Und es lag
daran, dass
das Debian auf den Maschinen
zu neu war für das
Ansible-Playbook, was drauf aufgespielt werden sollte.
Ein Debian war zu neu. Genau. Das hört man nie.
Das G-Streamer war halt zu neu und hat irgendwie nicht mehr mit der alten Vokto-Mix-Software zusammengehauen.
Und deshalb musste das arme Vok dann irgendwie über Nacht einfach auf allen Systemen das neue Pre-Alpha-Vokto-Mix 2 deployen.
Wo man dann eben in der Eröffnung festgestellt hat, dass eine bestimmte Transitionsfolge dafür sorgt, dass der gesamte Streaming-Core mal eben sackfaultet.
Ach du Scheiße.
Und da kann man dann eben so schön sagen, mit NixOS wäre das nicht passiert, weil nämlich dort dann eben die Konfiguration immer genau, also zumindest sobald sie mal gebaut wurde, immer an eine Softwareversion nicht gebunden ist, aber eben einfach koexistiert.
Also wenn du zurückrollst, dann rollst du halt in einen Snapshot zurück, in dem die Konfiguration gemeinsam mit der Software zurückrollt wird.
eröffnen sich mir eine Handvoll
Fragen. Und zwar, ich wollte gerade erst mal
fragen nach,
wir haben diese Nix-Sprache
erwähnt. Da stellt sich mir als erstes die Frage,
warum ist das eine Programmiersprache und nicht
einfach ein
JSON oder irgendwas,
das Deklarativ ist, aber das stelle ich mal nach hinten an.
Jetzt habe ich mir
gerade eben als unbedarfter
Linux-Anfänger, wie gesagt, ich benutze ja bloß
Autsch,
jetzt hat sich bei mir direkt die Frage
gestellt,
so ein Nix-Paket ist jetzt zum Beispiel
für mein Firefox, ist jetzt quasi
ein Ordner, wo dann wahrscheinlich auch nochmal trotzdem
eine Systemunterstruktur drin ist mit dem BIN-Ordner
und mit dem Lib-Fad und mit
dem ETC-Ordner wahrscheinlich.
Jetzt frage ich mich, wie verhält
sich jetzt in dem Paket
so Binaries und Libraries zur
Konfiguration, dass ich die zurückrolle
oder zurückrollen kann, beziehungsweise
wenn ich was an der Konfiguration ändere,
wie verhält sich das
dann so, dass ich das Paket zurückrollen kann,
aber meine eigene Konfiguration ist die denn auch
zurückgerollt? Wie sieht das an einem konkreten
Beispiel mal aus? Also, da gibt es
verschiedene Mechanismen,
weil letztendlich muss man
immer schon gucken, was jetzt die Software
braucht. Also,
der Optimalfall ist einfach, dass die Software,
also, es geht jetzt vor allem erstmal um,
ich würde jetzt eher von Serverdiensten,
Services und sowas reden, dass
die beispielsweise einfach als Kommandozahlen-Argument
oder meinetwegen auch als Environment-Variable
einfach eine Konfigurationsveränderung
gegennehmen, der nicht,
sodass der Pfad nicht Hardcode ist, sondern man
ihn als Argument mitgibt oder zumindest mitgeben kann.
So eine gute Zwölffaktor-Anwendung, also
quasi.
Ja, sorry. Genau. Jedenfalls, dass dann zum Beispiel
irgendwie, dass ich dem Apache, wenn er
startet, zusätzlich noch als Argument mitgeben
kann, wo liegt denn jetzt die Config? Und dann
wird beispielsweise, wenn wir nur die Konfiguration
ändern, aber die
Programmversion gleich bleibt, dann
bleibt der Apache, wird das Apache-Paket nicht
neu gebaut, aber der System-D-Service
wird neu gebaut und das Config-File
wird neu gebaut und in dem
neuen Systemd-Service wurde dann einfach der
Pfad zum Konfigurationsfall ausgetauscht.
Das ist so der einfachste
Fall.
Und dieses neue Paket ist eine komplette
Kopie von dem alten Paket?
Das Paket
selbst, der Apache selbst, wird gar nicht
kopiert, weil der liegt immer noch
unter demselben Path und wird dann
was neu gebaut wird,
ist eben das neue Konfigurationsfall.
Das landet wieder in einem anderen Ordner,
weil sich eben was verändert hat.
Und was neu gebaut wird, ist dann eben quasi die Instrumentierung,
die das Paket und die Konflikt zusammenbringt.
In diesem Fall dann der Systemd-Service,
wo dann einfach als Argument eben der Pfad zum Konflikt-File ausgetauscht wurde.
Und das heißt jetzt der Systemd-Service, der jetzt mal in Apache startet,
wo der Apache ein Nix-Paket ist
und meine Konfiguration ist ein anderes Nix-Paket quasi,
muss der jetzt Nix-Aware sein und wissen,
irgendwie ein anderes,
das auf eine andere
Art und Weise zusammenstricken muss,
oder gibt es da irgendwie ein Abstraktionslayer,
was es dann für jemanden, der es benutzt, dann doch wieder
wie ein normales Unix aussehen lässt?
Also der Abstraktionslayer,
als Nutzer hast du erstmal
nicht so sehr viel
direkt mit den Package-Build-Skripten zu tun,
wobei
deine Systemkonfiguration
und aber auch die Package-Build-Skripte und sowas sind alle
in derselben Sprache geschrieben, dieser Nix-Expression-Language,
aber solange du
im einfachsten Fall sieht das halt einfach aus wie so ein bisschen
Enhanced JSON.
Da kriegst du nicht mal zwangsläufig mit, dass es eigentlich eine
funktional Programmiersprache ist.
Aber genau da es nämlich eine funktional Programmiersprache ist,
werden eben einfach diese ganzen Dinge, zum Beispiel
dieser Systemd-Service bekommt dann eben einfach
das Paket und auch eben
die Konfiguration als Input
und konkateniert die dann im Zweifel einfach zusammen.
Der System-D-Service ist jetzt ein Shell-Skript quasi?
Letztendlich ist Nix eigentlich, wenn ich jetzt mal ein bisschen zynisch bin,
eigentlich nur eine sehr, sehr schöne Abstraktion darüber,
dass du zu spät merkst, dass letztendlich eigentlich dein gesamtes System
mit Bash gebaut wird und einfach schon zu involviert bist,
um schreiend wegzulaufen.
Also letztendlich baut die Nix-Expression-Language
immer nur irgendwelche Bash-Skripte zusammen,
die dann irgendwann vom Builder quasi in der Sandbox ausgeführt werden,
und dann das Paket rausfällt.
Das heißt, was zum Schluss rausfällt, ist ein erzeugtes, neu erzeugtes Bash-Skript.
Das liegt aber dann nicht in einem von den Paketen, denn es ist Output von den Paketen.
Das ist quasi der eigentliche Builder, das eigentliche Build-Skript.
Du schreibst eine Systemkonfiguration oder Programmbaubeschreibung und die erzeugt letztendlich einen Bash-Skript.
Und dieses Best Script wird dann eben ausgeführt,
um das Programm zu bauen.
Und das Bauergebnis ist dann eben das Paket,
was dann eben in diesem bestimmten Ordner lag.
Aber jetzt haben wir ja gerade gesagt,
dass die Konfiguration eventuell ein anderes Paket ist.
Genau.
Und was wird jetzt ausgeführt, wenn ich jetzt diesen...
Gehen wir mal davon was weg, was ein System-Ds-Service ist,
weil da passiert ja noch ganz anderes Zeug,
was ich gar nicht verstehe.
Aber zum Beispiel mein Firefox.
Mein Firefox, der erwarte ich als Anfänger,
dass ich unter
User bin Firefox
eine Binary finde, die ich ausführen kann.
Ist es unter Nix
immer noch so? Nein, ist es
nicht, denn Nix OS
und auch generell Nix,
alles, was von Nix verwaltet wird,
liegt unter
slash nix
und dann meistens slash store,
also zumindest fast alles
und es gibt eben
einfach keine
andere normale Ordnerstruktur mehr, wie du sie kennst.
das einzige, was es noch gibt, ist glaube ich
bin
bash und userbin
env
und der Rest, alle anderen
Vinerys liegen eben tatsächlich dann eben in
diesem Nick Store
und
tatsächlich wird eigentlich vor allem dein
Path modifiziert, das heißt
du rufst nicht mehr userbin
Firefox auf, sondern du rufst noch
Firefox auf und dann wird
eben anhand des Paths, der eben gerade
in deinem System-Environment
vorhanden ist, wird dann eben
dafür gesorgt, dass das richtige Binary
aufgerufen wird. Das heißt, meine
Pfadvariable ist dann einfach mal
3 Kilobyte groß, weil da irgendwie alle
Nix-Store unterordnen. Sie wird auf jeden Fall
Nennswert größer, ob sie jetzt 3 Kilobyte werden,
weiß ich nicht, aber es ist auf jeden Fall,
also es hat zumindest keine
Nennswert-Auswirkung irgendwie auf die
System-Performance. Ja, das meine ich auch nicht, aber
da muss ich jetzt nochmal kurz einhaken, und zwar ist es
nicht ganz so.
Ja.
Okay, und zwar, wenn man jetzt ein NixOS Rebuild Switch zum Beispiel ausfügt oder auch ein Xenv als benutzt außerhalb von NixOS,
was der dann zusätzlich noch macht, ist, sobald er dieses, bei NixOS alle Programme, die man jetzt zum Beispiel als installiert markiert,
oder als Pakete hat, die man immer zur Verfügung haben will, zum Beispiel, wie man Firefox benutzen will, in jeder Shell, egal was man da öffnet,
fügt man die halt mit in seiner Konfiguration
als Paket ein. Und was dann
NixOS Rebuild beim
Bauen noch macht, ist, dass es eine Art
Simlink-Baum anlegt,
wo zum Beispiel
ein BIN da drin
und in den BIN werden
jetzt alle Programme, die ich haben will,
werden dann halt immer die Binarys einfach
reingesimlinkt. Also dass der Name da drin steht
und das verlegt dann auf das Paket.
Und somit habe ich quasi wieder so ein Eintrag
in meinem, also wieder ein Verzeichnis,
den ich in meinen Path packen kann.
Das wäre dann bei Firefox,
wäre das dann,
wenn das jetzt lokal für
meinen UserPlus installiert ist,
dann liegt das jetzt in meinem Home-Verzeichnis
in.nix-profile-bin-firefox
und wenn das jetzt aber
jetzt irgendein Programm ist, was
global installiert ist, dann gibt es
in run-current-system-sw-bin
gibt es dann halt wieder auch so ein Verzeichnis,
weil einfach alle Programme, die ich jetzt über NixOS installiert habe,
dass die dann da drin zur Verfügung stehen.
Und damit wird mein Path in einem Normalfall nicht so groß.
Es wird bloß groß, wenn etwas größer wird.
Das heißt, der Paketmanager ist dafür verantwortlich,
diesen Baum an Simlings immer aktuell zu halten.
Genau.
Und wenn man jetzt upgradet oder downgradet,
dann wird halt neuer Simlingbaum erstellt
und dann wieder an die gleichen Pfad gepackt.
Stimmt.
Da habe ich tatsächlich ein bisschen zu sehr unterschieden, weil es geht eben tatsächlich darum, ob du jetzt ein Programm so installiert hast, dass du es eben installiert hast, um es zu benutzen, wie eben Firefox, dass du einfach Firefox eintippen kannst und Firefox startet.
dann wird eben tatsächlich dieser Simbling-Baum, der diverse Indirektionen hat, zusammengebaut, sodass du dann beispielsweise eben tatsächlich nur diesen Root-Ordner, dieses Simbling-Baums zu deinem Pfad hinzufügen musst.
Und aber eben, es können ja auch Programme gestartet werden, die dir relativ egal sind.
Du willst sie nicht irgendwie direkt von der Shell aufrufen können, aber andere Programme müssen sie zum Beispiel aufrufen, dann wird denen eben ein passender Path zusammengebaut.
Genau.
Also, wer jetzt jetzt Firefox oder Holken Anthos
Binary ausrufen würde,
dann würde das in seinem
eigenen Path drin liegen haben,
der dann über einen Shelf-Rapper gesetzt wird.
Cool.
Ja, ich würde einfach mal direkt zu Nix-Expression-Language
weitergehen. Juhu, lass uns über Programmiersprachen.
Ja, machen wir ja so selten hier in diesem Podcast.
Und so ein genereller Überblick, was
macht man damit? Beziehungsweise wissen wir ja, was man damit
macht jetzt, aber wie schaut das aus? Was kann das?
Und warum ist das eine vollwertige Sprache?
Und warum nutzt man nicht einfach
Jammel?
Also, die Nix Expression Language ist halt eine Domainspecific Language, die extra dafür gebaut wurde.
Und das Grundkonzept ist eben, dass man letztendlich einfach in einer schönen, funktionalen Sprache quasi Key-Value-Paare erzeugt, die man dann irgendwann in so ein Bash-Script reinjumpt.
Aber diese Sprache hat so ein paar Grundeigenschaften.
Also erstmal ist sie funktional, rein funktional.
Und das liegt daran, dass eben die Idee ist,
dass alles, womit irgendwie so ein Package-Build-Script rumverwirkt,
dass all diese Argumente explizit reingegeben werden müssen,
damit man eben auch weiß, worüber man jetzt eben diesen Hash berechnen muss.
Das klingt sehr sinnvoll.
Und aber auch, dass man das Ganze eben modular hält.
Und ich zum Beispiel einfach sagen kann,
okay, ich will das Ganze jetzt nicht gegen Python 3.7 bauen,
sondern nur gegen Python 3.5.
Und dann gebe ich der Funktion, die eben mein Programm baut, eben einfach nicht Python 3.7 als Argument mit, sondern Python 3.5.
Und dann tut es hoffentlich weiterhin immer noch.
Genau, das ist, warum diese Sprache funktional ist.
Und dann noch, diese Sprache ist auch lazy.
Das sorgt nämlich dafür, dass tatsächlich die gesamte Paketbeschreibung und Systembeschreibung ist halt einfach ein großes Programm, was zusammengelingt wird.
Und dadurch, dass die Sprache aber lazy ist, werden eben nur diese Teile ausgeführt, dieser gesamten System- und Programmbeschreibung, die tatsächlich benutzt werden, auf die tatsächlich zugegriffen wird.
Das heißt, es wird erst zur Benutzzeit von einem Paket dieses Stück Code dafür ausgeführt?
Genau. Also das Paket steht die ganze Zeit in dieser Liste aller Pakete drin.
Und aber erst, wenn du es irgendwo anders definierst, wird auch tatsächlich die Sub-Expression quasi evaluiert.
Und nix baut sich dann irgendwelche Fixpunkte zusammen und so weiter.
Und das hat auch so ein paar schönen Convenience-Features.
Da hängt dann auch jeweils immer noch für den Programmiersprachinterpreter
irgendwie so ein Kontext dran.
Das heißt, du kannst einfach, wenn du ein Skript schreibst,
wenn du ein Skript irgendwo hinschreiben willst,
dann kannst du einfach dort inline ein Paket referenzieren.
Und dann wird das Paket auch automatisch quasi gebaut
und auf dein System installiert und kann zugegriffen werden.
Also wenn ich irgendwie, ich kann ein Skript schreiben und dort dann einfach quasi inline.ls erwähnen, also Package.ls und dann wird dort, wird das vom Nix automatisch durch den Pfad zu ls ersetzt.
Jetzt aber nochmal ein Stückchen weiter zurück, bitte.
Wir reden ja von Paketmanagern.
Von Paketmanagern haben wir jetzt schon einige mal erwähnt
und die haben eigentlich immer eine deskriptive Sprache
als Beschreibungssprache.
NPM hat ihre Package-JSON, Rust hat seine Tommel-Datei.
Swift hat eine TWIFT-Datei.
Swift hat wieder eine ausführbare SWIFT-Datei
und RubyGems oder Bundler hat auch eine ausführbare Ruby-Datei.
Aber anflüssig war so mein Eindruck, dass man davon weggeht,
dass man unbedingt, wenn man ein Paket beschreibt,
dort beschreibt man erstmal nur die Dependencies von einem Paket.
Ich brauche dieses, jenes und drittes Paket in diesen Versionen.
Das ist der einfache Case.
Warum braucht man jetzt eine ausführbare,
also es ist ja schön, dass die funktional und lazy ist,
aber warum muss das überhaupt ausführbar sein?
Beschreibt man mit dieser Nix Expression Languages auch,
wie die Pakete gebaut werden,
ist das quasi so ein Bildsystem
und Paketmanager gleichzeitig,
wo das irgendwie vermischt.
Oder geht es nur um Escape-Patches
direkt mit einzubauen,
was du ja der Swift-Android
mit der Bildung erst machen kannst.
Genau, also an welcher Stelle,
warum muss es überhaupt ausführbar sein?
Jörg vielleicht.
Ja.
Und so war, was man ja mit,
was ja quasi nichts verheiratet ist,
Das ist an sich kein eigenes
Billsystem. Im Prinzip
an einer Stelle versucht es dann immer, ein anderes
Billsystem aufzurufen. Aber da es
halt so viele verschiedene Billsysteme gibt,
die man ja alle unter einen Hut bringen will,
gibt es da halt Abstraktionen
für in Nix.
Die sind dann halt auch in Nix beschrieben.
Die sind nicht irgendwie, dass die
in dem Nix-Package-Manager
irgendwo in dem Source-Code von dem
beschrieben sind, sondern die sind wirklich in Nix-Packages
mit drin. Die kann man auch selber
anpassen, dann gibt es noch verschiedene Varianten.
zum Beispiel
wenn man Python-Pakete baut
und die dann woanders
mit verbindet, dann muss ja
zum Beispiel mit Python, die dann in dem anderen
Bildprozess wiederführt wird, muss es ja dann
wie sind die denn zum Beispiel
in so einen Python-Path reingepackt werden
und dafür braucht man dann halt Abstraktionen
und deswegen ist es dann eine eigene Programmierbare.
Das heißt, was ist jetzt in einem
allgemeinen Beispiel
so der häufigste Use-Case
für einen programmierbaren Teil.
Alles, was ich bis jetzt von euch beschrieben bekommen habe,
klingt so, als könnte man das auch über eine Konvention
lösen, dass man bestimmte Sachen als
bestimmte Variablen in ein System
reingibt.
Du kannst das Ganze
so lange über eine Konvention lösen,
solange sich alles an diese Konvention
hält. Und wir haben halt einfach
mit unzähligen Bildsystemen
zu tun.
Schon für jede Programmiersprache
gibt es ja verschiedene Bildsysteme.
Und dann denken sich manche Leute
irgendwelche Special Flags aus,
oder du willst dann im Zweifel
noch irgendwie
verschiedene Varianten eines Pakets
erstellen, das heißt, du baust
dir dann letztendlich
wieder irgendwie
eine Funktion, die dann
verschiedene
Flavors davon aufruft
und insoweit,
also das bringt einfach
Also du meinst, es gibt irgendwo eine natürliche
Grenze für deklarative
Beschreibung in der Domäne.
Genau.
Es ist halt einfach eine gewisse Komplexität,
die du nur mit etwas
Deskriptivem erschlagen kannst.
Und sobald etwas aus dem Rahmen fällt,
bist du halt verloren.
Und die Frage ist jetzt, ob der
aktuelle Zustand,
also er ist besser, aber wie viel besser er ist,
denn du bist halt nicht verloren.
Du kannst halt deine Workarounds
oder zusätzlichen Abstraktionen schreiben,
aber das erhöht natürlich dann auch nochmal
die Komplexität des gesamten Codes.
Was sind denn jetzt also
die
wenn ich jetzt
mein Nix-Paket
beschreibe in dieser Nix-Expression-Language
und ihr habt gesagt, es gibt so gewisse Sachen, die man wiederverwenden
kann, wenn ich jetzt, gibt es sowas
in dieser Sprache wie
Libraries von Nix-Expression-Language
die ich mir als Dependency da mit
reinziehe, weil ich irgendwie Sachen mache, die
viele andere Pakete bereits auch machen
also C-Make
konfigurieren oder sowas, ist das dann
wieder selber ein Nix-Paket
sowas oder wie funktioniert sowas?
Ja, genau.
Gerade Nix-Paket.
Wer macht du, Nick?
Wenn es zum Beispiel
ein C-Mac zum Beispiel hat,
was man dann macht, ist, dass man
das jetzt ein Projekt ist,
wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel mit C-Mac baut,
dann gibt es
eine Paketbeschreibung für
das Programm, was man bauen will.
Da gibt es dann sogenannte Variable, die das Bildinput
und sobald man da das C-Mac-Paket
mit reinbaut, würde
die Abstraktion,
die die Nix-Packages-Button ist,
nicht bloß C-MAC
dem Bildprozess zur Verfügung stellen,
sondern auch gleichzeitig
den Bildprozess so verändern,
dass verschiedene
Phasen des Bildprozesses angepasst wird.
Zum Beispiel bei C-MAC muss man dann
an irgendeiner Stelle mal das C-MAC
aufrufen und eben auch
bestimmte Flags übergeben.
Und dann steht halt in der Abstraktion
von Nix-Packages-Pflegung
wird dann halt schon zum Beispiel ausgewählt, dass das ein
Release-Build wird und dass
das BIN verzeichnet halt
in dem Dotting gepackt wird,
wo dann das Paket auch reininstalliert werden soll
und dann muss man dann halt selber bloß
noch die, zum Beispiel die CMake Flex,
die man jetzt zusätzlich noch mit
verändern will,
noch mit angeben, aber
es gibt halt so eine gewisse Abstraktion,
die das ganze
Verschreiben von neuen Paketen
einfacher macht.
Genau, vielleicht noch mal ein bisschen
abstrakter, also zumindest
für so den klassischen Build-Prozess,
wo du halt irgendwie erst
den Build konfigurierst,
dann tatsächlich baust und dann installierst und vielleicht
noch testest und zwischendurch mal
wild rumpatchst, gibt's eben schon
in Nix-Packages, also das
ist eben dieses eine große
Git-Monorepo, was sowohl
alle offiziell
paketierten Nix-OS-Pakete
beschreibt und auch das Nix-OS-System.
Jedenfalls gibt's dort ein sogenanntes
Standard-Enf und das
das ist auch das, an dem sich meistens
die meisten
Package-Bilds irgendwie orientieren, weil das hat einfach
so eine gewisse Anzahl von Grundphasen,
eben tatsächlich irgendwie
Unpack, also
sich die Sourcen holen, sie entpacken,
sie konfigurieren, make, make, install
und hat eben dann auch
quasi schon eine gewisse,
schon eben eine Standard,
eine Standardkonfiguration
dieser Phasen, die eben einfach so ein klassisches
Autotools,
Configure Make Make Install Paket installieren kann
und
macht dann eben auch diese notwendige
Magic im Hintergrund, mit der du dich eigentlich nicht beschäftigen
willst, wie zum Beispiel
irgendwie
hartgecodete
Bash-Interpreter-Pfade raus
zu patchen. Und
je nachdem, womit du jetzt tatsächlich dann
zu tun hast, also wenn du jetzt zum Beispiel
mit C-Mac zu tun hast, kannst du eben einzelne
Phasen davon ersetzen
und zum Beispiel für C-Mac gibt es da eben auch
schon fertige Komponenten in diesen
Nix-Packages, wo du dann einfach nur sagst,
hier eben Build-Inputs,
CMake-Hook und dann hakt sich das da eben
rein,
ersetzt dann eben diese Configure-Phase,
dadurch, dass dann eben jetzt CMake aufgerufen
wird und dadurch
so Praxiserfahrung, ich benutze
jetzt halt NixOS seit ein bisschen
mehr als einem Jahr und bin jetzt aber auch schon
Package-Maintainer für die Dinge, die mir eben gefehlt haben
und tatsächlich geht man,
oder gehe ich zumindest immer so vor,
dass ich einfach erstmal so dieses Standard
Gerüst nehme
und dann eben gucke, welche Komponenten muss ich
austauschen, dann lasse ich es laufen, dann meckert
es meistens, dass irgendwelche Dinge fehlen und dann füge ich den zu
und dadurch
die Standardfälle
sind mittlerweile wirklich relativ gut abgedeckt,
dass die entweder schon
in dieses Muster passen oder du einfach nur bestimmte Teile
dieses Musters ersetzen musst.
Und
wenn wir dann jetzt zu anderen Sprachen,
wie beispielsweise
statt Zettelstus eben zu Rust
oder Python gehen,
haben dann eben tatsächlich Leute quasi nochmal Rapper darum geschrieben,
die sich gefühlt genauso verhalten oder ähnlich komfortabel verhalten,
als ob du jetzt beispielsweise auch wieder dieses MakeMakeInstagram machen würdest.
Bloß halt, dass sie eben die Python-Tools dafür aufrufen.
Und das inklude ich in meinen Nix-Expression-Language-Beschreibungsfile
irgendwie als Dependency?
Oder kopiere ich da ein Template-Projekt, was das alles beinhaltet?
Du referenzierst halt meistens einfach dieses Standard-Enf.
Die Standard-Enf ist eben auch wieder,
es ist halt eine funktionale Sprache,
das heißt, alles sind irgendwie Funktionen.
Also die Standard-Enf ist quasi die Standard-Bibliothek
für die Nix-Nel, wie ist die Kurzform, für diese Nix-Sprache.
Es gibt noch eine andere Standard-Bibliothek,
aber Standard-Enf ist quasi die Standard-Bilder-Beschreibung.
Also Standard-Enf beschreibt so diesen Standardfall
eines Programmbilders, den du haben willst.
Also da hast du dann die...
Und die modifizierst du dir dann eben so entsprechend
und gibst eben Argumente rein,
wie eben tatsächlich überhaupt erstmal welche Sourcen es bauen soll.
Da ziehst du dir einfach deine Funktionen her,
mit denen du sagst, ich weiß, das ist ein CMake-Projekt
oder das ist ein Bazel-Projekt oder das ist ein Swift-Projekt
und da ziehe ich mir jetzt aus meiner Standard-Enf
meine Komponenten, mit denen ich mir jeweils diese Projekte baue
und die sind konfigurierbar.
Du ziehst es dir nicht aus der Standard-Enf,
sondern die Standard-Enf ist halt eine Funktion,
die du entsprechend parametrisierst.
Die Standard-Enf nimmt eben so ein Set,
in der Nix-Expression-Language arbeiten wir halt die ganze Zeit
einfach nur mit Funktionen oder sogenannten Attribute-Sets,
Attribute-Sets sind halt einfach beliebig tief verschachtelte Sets, sowas ein bisschen wie JSON-Objekte.
Oder, ja, genau, Hashmaps, stimmt, tatsächlich.
Und diese Funktion, diese Standard-End-Bilder-Funktion nimmt halt irgendwie dann eben so ein Objekt entgegen,
so ein Set entgegen, wo du dem die ganzen Parameter mitgibst, wie eben tatsächlich,
welches, ja, wo liegen die Sourcen oder was sind die Sourcen
und eben welche Inputs soll es beim Bauen verwenden
und dort kannst du es dann eben entsprechend parametrisieren
und welche Flags soll es irgendwie dort ranhängen.
Genau.
So, jetzt, ich glaube, viel tiefer brauchen wir in dem Aspekt
noch nicht zu gehen, bevor es unanschaulich wird.
Ich habe jetzt mal noch in den Shownotes einen Thread verlinkt,
so ein Diskussionsforum-Thread,
warum eben der nochmal ein bisschen tiefer da reingeht,
warum eben nicht rein deklarative Sprachen wie Jamil beispielsweise
in NixOS verwenden werden, wenn das Leute nochmal tiefer interessiert.
Ah, das ist gut. Das wäre mal gut in Ruhe nachzulesen.
Ich meine, ich kann den Punkt auch schon nachvollziehen.
Vielleicht eine Sache noch.
Der Grund, warum man ja üblicherweise eben eigentlich nichts
Turing-vollständiges zur Paketbeschreibung benutzen will,
ist eben, da hängt halt ein ganzer Rattenschwanz an,
Security-Problem noch dran.
Also entweder ist die Frage natürlich, ob das ganze Zeug überhaupt terminiert.
aber eben will man auch nicht, dass es dann eben wild auf dem eigenen System rumschreibt.
Du willst eigentlich nicht, dass er zur Konfigurationszeit noch irgendwelche Logik ausfüllt.
Genau. Und zumindest diese Buildjobs, die finden tatsächlich für die meisten Plattformen mittlerweile einfach sehr, sehr gut sendgeboxt statt.
Das sorgt dann auch natürlich ein bisschen dafür, dass man, wenn man so Dinge wie Node.js-Dinge paketieren will, ein bisschen in Probleme rennt,
denn diese Sendboxes haben keinen Zugriff aufs Netzwerk.
Das heißt, du kannst eben kein normales
NPM-Install oder sowas ausführen, weil sie eben
nicht Dinge aus dem Internet runterladen können, weil
das wären ja auch wieder Seiteneffekte.
Da kann ich meinen Krypto-Miner ja gar nicht sauber...
Du kannst deinen Krypto-Miner schon ausführen, der wird
bloß seine Resultate nie irgendwo hinschicken können.
Schrott. Genau, und
quasi alles, was in dieser Sandbox...
Und den Seiteneffekt ist es auf jeden Fall.
Die Buildjobs werden eben tatsächlich einfach in einer Sandbox
ausgeführt, die eigentlich keinen
Zugriff aufs Internet hat. Der Krypto-Miner
könnte dein
Firefox patchen und dann
findest du dein
CryptoMiner-Ergebnis in den
Logs von deinen Web-Servern.
Nee, könnte er nicht.
Es sei denn, du gibst dort
auch Firefox noch als Fahrt mit rein.
Sonst hat er darauf kein Zugang.
Abgefahren.
Kann man da vielleicht dadurch, weil es die Sprache
vielleicht gut hergibt, auch irgendwie Static Analysis fahren?
Oder ist das nicht so?
Die Sprache ist auf jeden Fall dynamisch typisiert
und ich glaube,
kann man das?
Ich habe dazu ein paar Beispiele.
Und zwar, was man halt gut machen kann,
dadurch, dass man diese ganze Toolchain ziemlich gut unter Kontrolle hat
und dass man sagen kann, ich bau jetzt mal mein gesamtes System
mit einem Stippen-Compiler,
dass dann Leute anfangen, ihr gesamtes System
mit irgendwelchen LFM-Compiler-Plugins neu zu bauen
und dann dabei irgendwie so zur Laufzeit oder zur Compile-Zeit
noch irgendwelche Analysen drüber zu fahren, was irgendwie
nicht so einfach geht, wenn man irgendwie
ja, zum Beispiel bei so einem Packman oder so
wenn man dann anfangen würde, damit alles neu zu bauen
dann wäre das schwieriger, das so umzusetzen
und dann kann man das dann, dadurch dass es
einfach nur eine funktionale Programmier-Sprache ist,
tauscht man dann einfach nur den Compiler aus
und dann würde der das alles nochmal neu
bauen und ja, damit
lassen sich eigentlich ziemlich flexibel irgendwie
Dinge ausprobieren.
Cool. Also wie würde jetzt der Ablauf aussehen, wenn ich jetzt meine Dependency, wenn ich jetzt mein Firefox update, das heißt ich ziehe mir aus einem Online-Repository, gibt es eine neue Beschreibungsdatei dafür, die wird dann quasi gebaut, mit ein bisschen Glück habe ich aus dem Build-Cache kann ich mir einfach die Binary ziehen, muss die mir nicht selber bauen und dann wird die einfach in meinem System irgendwo daneben gelegt und dann gibt es einen Garbage-Collector, der sagt, du, da hast du noch ein altes Firefox, das benutzt du aber gar nicht mehr, das kann man jetzt wegnehmen.
schmeißen, ist das irgendwie so ein Ablauf, wie viel
funktioniert und soll das updaten? Also der
Garbage Collector ist ein separater Prozess, den du
explizit anstoßen musst
und dem sagst du dann auch meistens,
wie alte Pakete sein sollen
oder so, denn quasi jedes Mal
zumindest wenn du dein gesamtes System baust,
wird dann eben
quasi eine Art Garbage Collection
Root erstellt,
von dem aus man dann eben weiß, welche
Pakete jetzt zu diesem Systembild gehören und welche nicht.
Wann baue ich denn mein gesamtes
System?
Tatsächlich baust du eigentlich jedes Mal, wenn du die Konfiguration deines Systems veränderst oder eben die Software-Update ist, baust du dein gesamtes System neu.
Weil das eine Baumstruktur ist, quasi die miteinander.
Genau. Und man sagt tatsächlich, jede Konfigurationsänderung auf NixOS ist eben wie eine Neuinstallation des Systems, wenn man mal von diesen ganzen Stateful-Daten wie, ja keine Ahnung, dem Inhalt deiner Postgres-Datenbank oder was.
Kann ich das so ein bisschen verstehen wie,
jedes Update ist quasi ein neuer Commit in so einer Git-History
und von dort aus habe ich quasi eine gesamte Konfiguration,
die ich sehen kann und das ist quasi so ein Check-In
und ich kann auch zu einem vorherigen zurückgehen?
Nein, deine Systemkonfiguration musst du selbst versionieren.
Nur das Ergebnis deiner Konfiguration.
Ach so, was ist denn meine Systemkonfiguration?
Deine Systemkonfiguration ist einfach eben so ein,
quasi so ein Standmäßig so ein Attribute-Set,
Optionen, die du irgendwie konfigurierst.
Erinnerst du jetzt gerade von dem Beispiel, dass ich NixOS
verwende oder gilt das auch für, wenn ich einfach
bloß zusätzlich noch mit Nix-Pakete
auf einem
Ubuntu installiere? Was meinst du jetzt mit
Systemkonfiguration? Also eine Systemkonfiguration
gibt es natürlich nur unter NixOS, weil sonst kannst du ja
nicht dein gesamtes System konfigurieren.
Und was das Softwaremanagement angeht, gibt es tatsächlich
zwei verschiedene Varianten.
Entweder, es gibt natürlich
auch ein Kommandozahlen-Tool, das heißt...
Okay, aber dann erzähl mir doch mal bitte
jetzt bei NixOS
was ist diese Systemkonfiguration?
Also ich habe da, ich gehe jetzt davon aus,
ich habe in meinem System irgendwo
eine Datei liegen, die ist dann
Nix Expression Language oder sowieso und die
beschreibt, ich habe Firefox installiert, ich habe
ein Vim installiert
und das sind die aktuellen Versionen davon,
steht das da mit drin? Nein, das steht dort nicht drin,
sondern tatsächlich Nix,
die ganzen Programmbeschreibungen
liegen eben alle in diesem Nix Package
Git Repo und du kannst
entweder natürlich das Git Repo nehmen
oder standardmäßig wird das über sogenannte Channels
gelöst. Channels sind einfach letztendlich
nur quasi ein Stand
des Git-Repos,
die dir eben als...
Wie ein Git-Tag oder was?
Ja, genau.
Bevor jetzt zu weit rauskommen, was ist das?
Du hast auf jeden Fall erstmal,
wie das ganze Abläuft, können wir eventuell später noch behandeln,
aber du hast einfach quasi
einen aktuellen Stand
von eben diesem Monorepo,
wo eben eine Programmbeschreibung,
eine Bildbeschreibung für jedes Programm drin liegt
und
Konfiguration oder du änderst eben quasi
die Beschreibung aus diesem Repo
und dann wird dein System jeweils, und dann baust
du das System jeweils neu.
Also du kannst zum Beispiel,
wenn sich kein einziges Programm geändert hat
und du einfach nur deine Konfiguration änderst,
baust du trotzdem das System neu.
Aber die Programme haben sich halt,
müssen halt meistens dann nicht neu gebaut werden,
weil du ja eben an dem Programm selbst nichts geändert hast.
Der konsolidiert bloß diese beiden Sachen
wieder mit. Genau, oder du änderst dann deine
Konfiguration gar nichts. Was steht denn jetzt nur in meiner
Systemkonfiguration drin?
Da kann alles mögliche drinstehen,
weil wir es eben schließlich mit einer
Turing-Vorständigen-Funktion an Programmiersprache
haben. Aber normalerweise
willst du dort eben einfach nur relativ
simple Konfigur-Optionen haben,
wie irgendwie ja
services.sshd.enable
gleich true. Also da steht
drin, was für Services sind enabled.
Da steht drin, was ist installiert.
Genau.
Du hast dort eine Liste deiner installierten
Programme. Ja.
Zumindest mancher.
Und du schreibst eben auch natürlich
deine komplette Plattenaufteilung und sowas.
Also welche Traditionen wo gemountet werden.
Ach so.
Nix OS geht quasi,
wenn er bootet,
weiß erst mal nichts
und schaut dann nur in meine Systemkonfiguration rein.
Nein.
Also deine Iniz-Skripte und sowas
werden halt aus dieser Konfiguration gebaut.
Ah.
Also das System guckt zur Laufzeit
eigentlich nie in deine Konfiguration,
sondern die Laufzeit wird halt entsprechend
deiner Konfiguration so gebaut, dass sie tut, was
in der Konfiguration steht. Das sind die Dinge, die ich
jetzt unter anderem in den.files von
Mic finde unter slash nixOS, oder?
Ja. Genau.
Also wenn ich jetzt
mein System update,
ich gehe jetzt mal davon aus, es gibt
einen Paketmanager, der irgendwie
nixman heißt, oder
nee, dann
sage ich einfach update und dann zieht er quasi aus
diesem Monorepo, es gibt aktuelle
Stände von den Bilddateien für Firefox
oder so. Und dann
sagt er, da gibt es ein Binary oder
gibt es bereits ein gebautes Paket für, das ziehe ich
einfach runter. Und dann muss ich da mein System
neu starten?
Nee, gerade eben nicht. Also zumindest für alles,
was keine Kernel-Updates sind, muss dein System nicht neu starten.
Denn eben dieses Nixos Rebuild
Switch, das switcht eben tatsächlich
zur neuen Systemkonfiguration. Insofern
das eben auch guckt, gibt es Services, die sich
verändert haben? Und wenn ja, dann
startet es diesen Service automatisch neu.
Das heißt, bei fast allen Dingen
die irgendwie nicht kaputt sind
und nicht der Kernel sind,
wechselst du damit dann automatisch quasi zur neuen
Konfiguration. Das heißt, es geht alles mal kurz aus
und dann wieder an? Genau, also zumindest eben
Service, die irgendwie von Systemd verwaltet werden.
Dein Firefox musst du natürlich selbst neu starten.
Ach, okay.
Und eben deinen Window-Manager und sowas.
Wenn sie gestartet sind, dann laufen
sie natürlich auf dem Stand, der ja sowieso
noch auf der Platte rumliegt und aber auch im Rahmen liegt,
laufen sie halt einfach weiter. Das heißt, wenn
ich das mit Systemd oder
Login-D verknüppert habe, dann kann ich mal kurz
sagen, ich logge mich mal kurz aus, ich logge mich neu ein und dann ist meine neue KDE-Version
am Spaß. Genau. Und jetzt
muss ich doch noch die beiden verschiedenen Arten des Software-Managements ansprechen.
Und die sind vor allem dann relevant, wenn man nix-as verwendet, aber
es gibt erstmal ein Kommandozeilentool, das heißt nix-env.
Das ist halt so, wie man es zum Beispiel von Upget oder Pac-Man kennt.
Du sagst dann eben, ich benutze es nicht, deswegen kann ich jetzt auch gar nicht die genaue
Syntax sagen, aber du sagst halt einfach hier nix-env, install, Firefox oder sowas.
Und das ist dann eben quasi die, dann geht es eben nach, guckt irgendwie, ja, und installiert halt einfach Firefox, wie wir es schon die ganze Zeit gesagt haben.
Oder du sagst eben, du schreibst eine Konfigurationsdatei an die Stelle, wo die Liste der installierten Programme sind, schreibst eben noch Firefox rein und baust das System neu.
Ich persönlich bin ein sehr großer Freund von eben dieser deklarativen Software-Management, wo du eben jedes Mal das Config-Fall.
Aber das andere würde da auch reinschreiben.
Nein, das ist nämlich das Problem. Das andere schreibt in eine Datenbank
und akkumuliert dann wiederum State,
der nicht von deiner
Systemkonfiguration abgedeckt ist.
Und wann wird das synchronisiert?
Es wird gar nicht synchronisiert.
Und dementsprechend bin ich eigentlich ein großer Freund,
dass ich irgendwie alles, was ich auf meinem System haben will,
eben in meine Config reinschreibe und dann einfach quasi
jedes Mal das System neu baue
und dann wird die Software eben automatisch installiert.
Es ist so, als ob du in einem Docker-Container einfach Dinge machst
und Docker-Commit am Ende ausführst und die Änderungen hast,
aber die stehen nirgendwo deklariert vorher als
Convictor. Genau.
Das heißt, wenn du dein Firefox updatest,
dann gehst du in deine Systemkonfiguration
und sagst hier, ich
mach da jetzt aus einer
73 eine 54. Nein, mach ich nicht, weil
dort nämlich nur Firefox drin steht und
die Version von Firefox wird
eben ausschließlich durch diesen quasi
Git-Repo-Checkout bestimmt.
Das heißt, wenn ich mein System updaten will,
dann ziehe ich mir quasi
den neuesten Stand dieser Software-Beschreibung, den neuesten Stand
von diesem Git-Repo, Git-Branch
und sowas und ich muss
meine... und sobald dort, wenn
dann einfach auch das Objekt Firefox
einfach auf eine neuere
Package-Baubeschreibung jetzt zeigt,
dann wird eben das System
anhand dieser aktualisierten Beschreibung
neu gebaut. Das heißt, es wird halt ein neuerer Firefox gezogen.
Das heißt, sobald ich
ein Firefox neu starte, würde er sehen,
dass das nicht mehr konsistent ist und
einen anderen Firefox runterladen und starten.
Also den neueren runterladen.
Naja, du musst
das Bauen eines Systems immer explizit anstoßen.
Okay, also ich mache
ein Checkout quasi von dieser Systemkonfiguration,
dann steht da plötzlich eine neue Firefox-Version
drin, dann sag ich System bauen
und dann hab ich ein neues Firefox.
Genau.
Also es steht quasi
in dem, was du in seiner Systemkonfiguration
... Deine Systemkonfiguration
ändert sich natürlich nicht dadurch, dass du
einfach einen neuen Git-Checkout machst, sondern
du schreibst halt einfach in deine Systemkonfiguration
rein Firefox und irgendwo
in diesen Mix-Packages steht dann eben hier
Firefox wird eben aus diesem
File importiert und wenn dieses File eben verändert
wird, dann... So, und jetzt hast du aber
gesagt, es ist super praktisch, da mehrere
Versionen zu haben
oder Rollbacks zu machen, also mit
mehreren Versionen von dem Firefox.
An welcher Stelle kann ich jetzt zum Beispiel
sagen, ich möchte hier eine andere
Version davon aufrufen?
Oder wie würde... Fangen wir mal anders
an. Wenn ich jetzt merke, die Version hat
irgendwie einen Bug, ich möchte zurückrollen auf die
vorherige Version, an welcher Stelle muss ich das
machen? Muss ich dann plötzlich meine Systemkonfiguration,
die Version hart rein
coden oder kann ich da auch einen Befehl ausführen,
der nur Firefox und sonst nichts zurückrollt?
Wie funktioniert das?
Also erstmal kannst du dein gesamtes,
zumindest dieser Standard-Rollback-Mechanismus
rollt halt immer dein gesamtes System zurück.
Das heißt, im Zweifel
haben wir jetzt ja ein Szenario, wo du deine Systemkonfiguration
gar nicht verändert hast, aber einfach eben quasi
die Softwarebeschreibung sich aktualisiert hat
und deshalb ein neuerer Firefox installiert wurde.
Diese
ganze alte Systemtree,
Simlink-Tree liegt ja immer noch rum.
Das heißt,
das Rollback passiert einfach dadurch,
dass du einfach wieder einen Simlink
anders setzt und dann wieder bei dem alten
System-Tree bist. Und dadurch ist
eben alles, was ist eben
dein System, wie es
zuletzt gebaut war, eben wieder
so, wie es zuletzt gebaut war.
Das heißt, ich setze, achso,
es werden immer neue
Versionen von diesen Simlink-Bäumen
erzeugt? Oder muss ich
innerhalb von diesem Simlink-Bäumen?
Es werden immer neue Simlink-Bäume aufgebaut.
Das klingt jetzt so, als ob ich nur mein gesamtes System zurückrollen kann.
Das ist zumindest erst mal dieser trivialste Rollback-Mechanismus.
Wenn wir jetzt zum Thema mehrere Versionen gehen,
dann kannst du natürlich auch einfach
quasi statt
kannst du einfach noch
eine neue,
eine alte Version von Firefox natürlich einfach noch einen neuen Namen geben.
Also statt, dass du Firefox dann reinschreibst,
kannst du dann auch sagen,
irgendwie Firefox
Firefox Old, dem du dann einfach,
das ist ja wiederum eine Funktion,
die einfach alles Mögliche als Funktionsargument entgegennimmt.
Kannst du einfach sagen Firefox Old
und dem dann einfach eine alte Version der Sourcen mitgeben.
Oder eben die Paketbeschreibungen sind natürlich auch,
sind natürlich einfach ein Git-Repo.
Das heißt, du checkst dann einfach eine alte Version von diesem File aus.
Das heißt, ich könnte mir auch einfach die Beschreibung
von dem Firefox-Klonen in meinem Bereich.
Und was du gerade beschrieben hattest,
wenn ich den Simlink einfach umsetze,
das würde aber nicht verhindern, dass ich mit dem nächsten
Update dann wieder die neue Version
von Firefox drüber rolle, weil das System
weiß ja in dem Moment gar nicht, dass ich das zurückgerollt
habe.
In dieser Systembeschreibung
ist jetzt also nicht prinzipiell vorgesehen,
dass ich sagen kann, ich möchte aber von
Firefox immer Version 72 haben
und den Rest kannst du dann...
Dann musst du halt das Git-Repo forgen, wo du dann einfach
dafür sorgst, dass du dir quasi alle
Änderungen von Upstream reinziehst, bloß eben
den Firefox immer noch auf dieser alten Version hältst.
Da kann ich auch noch was anmerken.
Und zwar, was man auch machen kann, ist, dass man
dieses Nix-Package,
also man kann zum Beispiel auch Pakete pinnen auf eine bestimmte
Version, dadurch, dass Nix-Packages
einfach nur ein Git-Repos
ist, kann man ja auch sagen,
ich importiere mir jetzt in mein
aktuelles System jetzt noch
zusätzlich
Nix-Packages in der alten Version oder auf dem
fixen Stand
und tue dann aber nur,
dass Firefox aus dieser Version mir
in mein System reinziehen und lasse dann den
quasi auf das Aktuelle.
Oder man kann auch sagen,
ich nehme jetzt das Firefox-Paket
und
also diese ist dann wie eine Art Variable
in meiner Nix-Sprache
und kann man die dann auch anfangen zu überschreiben,
dass man sagt, man kann dann
Teile dieses
Build-Prozesses anpassen und zum Beispiel
sowas wie, von welcher Quelle baut
jetzt dieses Paket und dann an der Stelle
zum Beispiel dann sagen, jetzt bauen wir mal
Firefox aus einer anderen Version oder so, indem ich da
einfach die
URL ändere und
dann kann man
damit auch Änderungen oder verschiedene
Versionen von Programmen in seinem System
reinziehen. Beziehungsweise, was wir halt
in Nix-Packages selber machen, ist,
dass wenn wir irgendwie Programme haben, die problematisch
sind, also die wir zum Beispiel
Programmier-Sprachen, Compiler, Library
oder bestimmte System-Libraries,
die mit Versionen brechen,
wenn wir davon verschiedene Versionen brauchen, dann
maintainen wir die halt da
und dann kann man dann, die haben dann halt
anderen Namen. Also dann kann man die dann,
ja gut, es gibt es ja dann wahrscheinlich auch bei Arch
oder so, dass man dann verschiedene Versionen von
Programmen dort hat und dass die dann
auch ein bisschen anderen Namen hat, aber bei Nix hat man dann
halt den Vorteil, dass die dann auch,
dass man dann bestimmte Programme nicht anpassen
muss, dass es jetzt diese spezielle Version nimmt,
sondern dass das sauber
über dieses Sandboxing
und über diesen Nix-Store
voneinander getrennt ist.
Und dass du natürlich auch einfach die
Beschreibung des eigentlichen Programms nicht ändern musst,
weil in der Programmbeschreibung selbst
steht dann zum Beispiel einfach mal Boost drin
und du kannst halt einfach
über das Argument, was du in die Funktion reinreichst, entscheiden,
ob es jetzt ein Boost 1, 6 oder 2, 3,
ich habe keine Ahnung, wie die Version hier runtergerad ist.
Auf jeden Fall musst du die Programmbeschreibung
selbst dann nicht anpassen, solange es eben
immer noch dagegen baut.
Aber du reichst halt einfach unterschiedliche Versionen rein.
Und wieder zum Thema
mehrere Versionen gleichzeitig.
Das ist eben, wenn man beispielsweise
NixOS gibt es
üblicherweise, wird üblicherweise zweimal pro Jahr
als Stable Release veröffentlicht
und dann gibt es eben dieses
Rolling Release, was halt
Unstable ist und ich
persönlich benutze zum Beispiel einfach die Stable Version,
aber wenn es dann doch mal ein Programm gibt,
was ich eben aus dem
Unstable brauche, dann importiere ich mir einfach quasi
die Paketbeschreibung aus Unstable
und kann es einfach trotzdem
parallel installieren, auch wenn es mir irgendwie
im Zweifel sogar schon noch eine zusätzliche
neue LibC installiert, weil diese LibC
wird dann eben ausschließlich für diese
Programme verwendet, weil das eben alles entsprechend
gekapselt ist. Das ist geil, also das heißt, man kann
quasi so schöne Mischungen
aus dem Arch Linux und dem Debian-Ansatz
fahren. Ich nehme die abgehangene Version,
die einmal im Jahr released wird, aber für
mein Firefox oder
Rust-Compiler
ziehe ich mir einfach immer die Unstable-Version,
weil ich weiß, das ist einfach Vanilla-Upstream
und das kann ich so nehmen. Genau, der legt mir dann, der legt
dann halt zwar für die Version dann einfach immer noch
die neuere Version daneben, die dann
eben nur von diesem einen Programm verwendet wird
im Zweifel. Das heißt, natürlich habe ich
ein bisschen mehr belegten Plattenplatz,
aber ansonsten interagieren
die halt einfach nicht miteinander, obwohl sie parallel
rumliegen.
Cool. Würdet ihr jetzt sagen,
NixOS ist ein
System, was er einfach,
ich meine, ihr seid ja auch beide jetzt Leute,
die nicht nur
Benutzer von Nix sind, sondern ihr seid auch beide
Maintainer von Paketen und ihr beschäftigt euch
offenbar sehr intensiv damit.
ist jetzt
NixOS auch empfehlenswert
prinzipiell für Leute, die
wie gesagt, die Linux-Anfänger sind und einfach
das Arch benutzen und
sich nicht so intensiv damit beschäftigen
ist da ein gewisser Mehraufwand
mit verbunden oder
könnte ich jetzt morgen auch mal eben wechseln
Also vielleicht könnte ich da mal, also ich benutze
jetzt NixOS seit ein bisschen mehr als einem Jahr
und vielleicht, ich hab da auf jeden Fall
jetzt halt noch ein bisschen frischeren Blick drauf als
Nick, der da jetzt irgendwie seit Jahren
irgendwie einer der aktivsten Contributors war
deshalb würde ich vielleicht einfach mal so meine Einstiegserfahrung
berichten, also
wenn du das Base-Level
auf Arch Linux setzt, dann würde ich
sagen, ja, man kann schon umsteigen, es ist
trotzdem kleiner Aufwand, also NixOS
hat schon eine relativ steile Lernkurve
aber ansonsten
und NixOS
für NixOS musst du natürlich keine Scheu vor der
Kommandozeile haben, es gibt halt einfach noch keinen
Aber ich muss nicht unbedingt die Programmiersprache
kennen. Solange
sämtliche Software, die du benutzen willst
auch schon dort ist, dann musst du diese Programmiersprache
nicht besonders gut können.
Du musst halt in der Lage sein, irgendwie
deine Systemkonfiguration in dieser Sprache abzufassen,
was aber dann eben meistens nur irgendwelche
Config-Optionen auf True, False
oder eben
so setzt und
daraus dann eben das System baut.
Das ist ja in einer gewissen Hinsicht auch fast einfacher,
weil ich nur diese eine Konfiguration
habe und nicht irgendwie 35 unterschiedliche
Dateien in meinem ETC-Ordner anpassen
muss ich. Genau.
Und ja, man muss schon sagen, dass Nexus schon eine gewisse Lernkurve hat.
Das liegt auch daran, also du musst natürlich diese Sprache so ein bisschen lernen
und die Dokumentation ist auch so ein bisschen aufgeteilt.
Aber gerade wer irgendwie mit Artstellungsrumfrickelt, sagen wir so, Artstellungsverläufe...
Ja, das mache ich jetzt bloß Spaß, aber ich meine, der ist ja immer, der vielleicht von Ubuntu kommt
oder der nur so immer mal ein bisschen mit Linux zu tun hat
und vielleicht meiste Zeit Mac benutzt oder sowas.
Ja, da würde ich persönlich sagen,
muss man tatsächlich abwägen.
Weil Nix, das bietet natürlich,
unter Nix zuerst zerschießt du dir halt dein System nicht so schnell
und wenn es einmal funktioniert, dann funktioniert es halt auch wieder
und du kriegst es nicht so schnell kaputt.
Aber wie gesagt, du musst dich halt schon ein ganz kleines bisschen
intensiver damit beschäftigen.
Was passiert denn, wenn ich aus Versehen
diese Konfigurationsdatei
editiere und dann
mit einem Syntaxfehler speicher und dann
mein System durchstarte?
Dann wirft ihr halt das Rebuild-Tool entgegen,
dass da ein Syntaxfehler drin ist.
Das heißt, das ist nur zur Bildzeit.
In der Zeit wird ja nichts gelesen.
Stimmt.
Also, ja genau,
ich habe halt vorher erst irgendwann mal
Art-Studiums- und dann jahrelang Gentoo benutzt.
Das heißt, ich bin schon ein bisschen Schmerzen gewohnt,
ja, also ich habe mich halt einfach
vorher eine Woche hingesetzt,
als ich mal irgendwie ein bisschen Zeit hatte,
ein bisschen in der VM rum experimentiert
und geguckt, dass irgendwie
die meiste Software, die ich brauche, da ist und dann
habe ich eben
das, habe ich mir eben nichts so als installiert
und
genau, am Anfang
muss man halt, es ist schon ganz praktisch, wenn man irgendwie
eine Beispiel-Config hat,
da habe ich mich eben an der von MIG orientiert,
wobei die mittlerweile relativ komplex geworden
ist. So, da schauen wir noch mal ganz
kurz rein. Also eine der Sachen, die wir hier in den
Show Notes haben, wenn ich es wiederfinde,
ist, dass der MIG auf
GitHub so eine
Konfiguration mit den
.files,
man hat das häufig, dass Leute so ihre
.files auf GitHub stellen
und das ist so die Konfiguration für die Tools,
die Leute in ihrem Home-Verzeichnis haben, aber was
steht denn jetzt hier in den.files von
dir,
MIG, alles drin, was hast du da?
Ja,
Ich würde sagen, so einfach halber, es gibt jetzt ein Verzeichnis, das ist jetzt nichts zu essen,
eine Turing-Maschine, das ist dann jetzt mein Laptop.
Und da ist dann halt meine Configuration-Punktnix drin.
Und an der notiere ich dann halt ein paar Module, die ich mir selber geschrieben habe.
Also das sind dann einfach nur so andere Dateien.
Das ist quasi eine Art, wie man das aufsplittet.
Dass man zum Beispiel ein Modul hat, wo ich jetzt zum Beispiel meinen Bindomanager konfigriere.
Oder dann habe ich ein anderes Modul.
ich habe so ein YubiKey,
das ist so ein
Token,
auf dem man sein SSH-Key speichern kann
und das ist dann eine andere Datei.
Und das Schöne an diesem Konzept ist, dass man dann zum Beispiel
sagen kann, okay, wenn ich jetzt so eine eigene Datei habe,
dann kann ich die auch jemand anderem geben und dann kann er dann
auch sich zum Beispiel, wenn es ein YubiKey
sich konfrieren wird, ist einfach die ganze Datei kopieren
und dann hat das Design-System
quasi genau den gleichen Stand wie ich
und ich muss nie erst ein ewig langes Tutorial
schreiben, was man alles in welchen Dateien editieren
muss, um dann zum Ergebnis zu kommen.
und
ja, dann
kann man sich einfach seine
Dienste da,
die man braucht, aktivieren oder
seine Zeitzone setzen oder
sein
Playout von der Tastatur
oder was auch immer man braucht oder
zum Beispiel einen lokalen
Webserver laufen. Das macht man alles in der
Systemkonfiguration von Nix?
Ja.
Genau, das mache ich alles damit.
Und das Schöne ist dann halt, man macht es halt
einfach richtig und dann ist es halt, wenn ich
einen neuen Rechner hätte oder so, dann kann ich das wieder
genauso switchen
und dann ist es halt wieder genauso. Oder wenn ich jetzt
meine Festplatte stirbt und ich muss das aus dem Backup
nehme ich jetzt meine Programme,
eben mit rein backupe,
wenn ich das wieder aus dem Backup restauren muss,
dann kann ich halt einfach wieder diese Konfiguration ausführen
und dann ist es halt wieder genauso.
Und ja,
man kann dann halt auch so, wenn man bestimmte
irgendwie Dienste hat, die man jetzt
auch anders konfiguriert hat,
einen Rechner und dann die auf einen anderen Rechner brauchen,
aber dort ein paar Sachen anders habt, dann kann man
die sich halt schon in Modul aufteilen und hat
die dann noch viel in Rechnen. Und es ist halt
nicht so ein großer Schmerz wie Ansible,
wo halt irgendwie
man gegen den Paketmanager
arbeitet, weil der Paketmanager
zum Beispiel auch Dienste neu startet und dann
will man mit Ansible Dienste neu starten, sondern das ist halt
so ein Guss und das harmoniert dann
miteinander.
Vielleicht jetzt nochmal
zu dem Thema, wie tief muss man da
am Anfang drinstecken, irgendwie in diesem
ganzen Nix-Expression-Language.
Also man sollte sie schon zumindest
in Grundzügen lesen können, weil, was ein bisschen
schade ist, viele
Pakete bieten
an, dass du dadurch, dass du
eine bestimmte Flag setzt,
eben bestimmte Dinge aktivierst.
Und da gibt es aber derzeit noch keinen
vernünftigen Mechanismus, das irgendwie zu advertisen.
Das heißt zum Beispiel, der Standard-Tor-Browser
beispielsweise, der baut
halt standmäßig nicht gegen Puls Audio,
aber da ich hier eben ein KDE-Plasma mit Puls Audio am Laufen habe,
muss ich dann natürlich dem noch explizit als Argument mitgeben,
dass er mit Puls Audio bauen soll.
Das heißt, ich muss schon im Zweifel,
es ist schon sehr praktisch, wenn du zumindest siehst,
dass es dort diese Funktionsargumente gibt.
Also du hättest gerne Code Completion für deine Konfigurte,
die dir sowas mitgeben.
Das ist halt der Hauptkritikpunkt einer nicht-deklarativen Sprache
für solche Konfigurationen und musst sie halt ausführen,
um gewisse Aussagen darüber treffen zu können.
Genau, wobei zumindest was so normale Systemkonfigurationsoptionen angeht,
gibt es auch einfach auf der NixOS-Webseite eine schöne Suchmaschine,
wo du einfach nach Optionen suchen kannst.
Das klingt praktisch.
Und die dann auch direkt auf den Teil der NixOS-Dokumentation verlinken,
wo die sich eben beispielsweise mit diesen Dienst und mit dieser Config-Option beschäftigen.
So was kann man nicht gleich für diverse andere Pakete auch mitbauen,
dass die da automatisch geschaut werden, was da für Config-Optionen liegen
und dafür eine schöne Suchmaschine.
Nee, also diese Suche basiert eben darauf,
was Leute in die Dokumentation geschrieben haben.
Das ist ein bisschen auf der Dokumentation, okay.
Genau.
Ah, okay, das hätt ich gerne.
Also sowas wie, wenn jemand die Use-Flags von Gentoo kennt,
sowas gibt es leider nicht, dass du irgendwie global sagen kannst,
hier alles, was mit Opus gebaut werden kann,
soll auch mit Opus bauen.
Das funktioniert leider noch nicht.
Ich hätte noch mal was zur Konfiguration,
was halt auch ein cooles Feature ist von diesen Nix-Funkern.
so als Modulen, mit denen man die Teamstick konferiert ist,
dass das wiederum dann so ein eigenes
Typsystem hat,
wo dann zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwie eine Option,
wenn man sich da verschreibt oder irgendwie den
falschen Wert zuweist, dass es das dann
quasi abfängt oder wenn man zum Beispiel
verschiedene Konfigurationsoptionen setzt, die miteinander
im Konflikt stehen, dass es das halt schon zur
Evolutionszeit
abfängt und dann
in lesbare Fehlermeldungen
rausgibt und so, dass man
bevor man überhaupt irgendwie sein System
falsch konfiguriert und dann meinetwegen jetzt
irgendwie sein Web-Server oder
E-Mail-Server nicht mehr erreichbar
im Internet zur Verfügung steht, dass das schon
gewisse Sachen geprüft werden und
ja.
Also dieses Modul-System von
Nix-S ist da schon ganz praktisch.
Das heißt,
das verhindert, dass ich mein System
falsch konfiguriere und dann
mit einer falschen Konfiguration neu starte?
Zumindest in gewissen
Grenzen, ja.
Da würde mich interessieren, ob es irgendwie die Möglichkeit gäbe,
dass ich sagen kann, also mein System läuft jetzt einmal,
aber hier ist eine andere Konfiguration.
Baue es doch mal damit neu und starte das mal.
Und wenn ich, so wie weißt du,
wenn du die Bildschirmkonfiguration änderst?
Dafür gibt es zum Beispiel Nixos Bild VM,
was dir aus deiner Systemkonfiguration,
ich glaube, QEMU VM erstellt und die startet.
Und dann kannst du halt erst mal...
Im nächsten Stand schon mal ausprobieren,
bevor du da hinspringst.
Das ist cool.
Oder du kannst eben erst mal die Konfiguration nur bauen
und dann eben auf dein Testsystem schieben.
und dort dann erstmal durchtesten,
bevor du dann exakt die gleiche Konfiguration
dann auch auf dein Produktivsystem neu baust.
Nicht schlecht.
Genau.
Vielleicht nochmal zu den typischen Einstiegsproblemen.
Also einerseits ist die Dokumentation von NixOS
derzeit noch nicht so ganz optimal,
weil sie ist halt etwas fragmentiert.
Also wir würden gerne möglichst viele Artstellungsnutzer einbinden,
damit die uns mal ein vernünftiges Wiki bauen.
Also es gibt derzeit ein inoffizielles Wiki.
Also das Wiki gehört nicht zur inoffiziellen Dokumentation, aber ist, finde ich, immer ein sehr, sehr guter Einstiegspunkt.
Und dann gibt es eben für Nix-Zus ein Manual.
Für Nix-Packages, also quasi diese Paketbeschreibung, gibt es ein Manual.
Die ist dann besonders relevant, wenn man irgendwie selbst Dinge paketieren will.
Und dann gibt es auch noch für den Nix-Paketmanager selbst irgendwie ein Manual, aber das braucht man relativ selten.
wenn man in diesen
Manuals nichts findet, dann ist es
immer ganz gut, irgendwie in die Issues vom
Nix-Package-Gitab-Repo zu gucken.
Ob da schon jemand festgestellt hat, dass Dinge kaputt sind
oder ob man da irgendwelche Workarounds findet.
Und wenn alle Stricke
reißen, dann fragt man halt im
Discourse-Forum nach
oder irgendwie im
IRC-Channel auf Freenode. Das ist so meine
Herangehensweise.
Und
auch ganz schön ist noch,
du kannst
eine aktive, es gibt quasi eine
Reppel, also quasi
ja, ein Interpreter.
Nix-Shell oder sowas? Genau.
Nix-Shell ist halt was anderes.
Es gibt halt quasi einen Interpreter, in den du
deine aktuelle Systemkonfiguration reinladen kannst
und dann auch sämtliche Konfigurationen und sowas
eben dir angucken kannst.
Super praktisch.
Genau, das ist die Nix-Reppel.
Und ja, so ein
Standardkommando kann ich ja mit in die Show-Nutz packen.
Also mich würde zum Beispiel mal interessieren, wenn ich jetzt
irgendwie, weil ihr das vorhin beschrieben habt, wenn jetzt jemand
hornaltes System hat, auf dem man sich einloggen muss,
aber hätte gerne die neuen Tools.
Gibt es da auch eine Möglichkeit, dass ich sage, ich lade mir
für dieses System jetzt dieses eine Nix-Tool
runter, mit dem ich mir dann
den Rest von meinem System, was ich gerne
haben würde, bootstrappen kann, um dann so eine
Nix-Shell zu starten, wo dann mein Vim
und mein Compiler und mein
Git drin ist.
Wie heißt das? Wonach muss ich da suchen?
Ja, also du kannst halt auf jedes System
diesen Nix-Package-Manager installieren.
Standardmäßig wäre es
ganz gut, wenn du Root-Rechte hast.
Ich hab jetzt keine Root-Rechte.
Standmäßig richtet der sich halt irgendwie
das direkt Slash Nix ein.
Da gibt es aber einen schönen Rapper
für Systeme, die eben User-Namespaces
können.
Das heißt
Nix-User-CH-Root.
Und das wirft halt
den ganzen Nix-Kram in so eine Sandbox,
wo ausschließlich eben dieser Nix-Pfad
irgendwie virtuell
quasi rein... Das wäre für mich schon mal
ein schöner Einstieg, um das mal auszuprobieren.
dass ich sage, mein Firefox
oder so installiere ich jetzt über nix stattdessen.
Genau. Und ansonsten
installiert man nix halt irgendwie über
so ein schönes CurlPipe
SHA. Also, ne genau,
es gibt also so ein schönes CurlPipe
SHA, womit ich denn in meinem
Home-Verzeichnis schon mal irgendwie
so ein Subset von nix-Paketen quasi installieren
könnte, so wie Rustup
oder diese ganzen
Skripte, die sich so bootstrappen. Genau, Mick, du
lässt ja regelmäßig irgendwie nix auf irgendwelche
Unimaschinen los, oder?
Ja, genau. Also irgendwie
High-Performance-Rechner,
wo irgendwie so ein Debian
drauf ist, wo ich nie nach Hutrechnen
gefragt habe, aber glücklicherweise User-Name-Spaces
anfangen. Und dann habe ich da einfach
mein Nix in mein Home rein installiert.
Und ja,
dann kann man dann damit schön
arbeiten.
Also dann ist es mir auch relativ egal,
ob ich jetzt auf dem Ubuntu bin oder so, weil ich jetzt
einfach bloß entwickle, weil dann brauche ich halt nur die
Programme, die ich jetzt zum entwickeln brauche, mein Editor
dann kann ich die halt alle schön mit Nick verwalten
und dann wenn ich jetzt zum Beispiel nur
Programme für meinen
eigenen Nutzer installieren will
dann gibt es dann noch sowas, das heißt Home Manager
der würde dann halt so
bestimmte Konfigurationen
auf meiner, für meinen Benutzer
könnte den
wieder automatisch einrichten, also wenn ich zum Beispiel irgendwie
MPD oder
ein Emacs Demon oder sowas starten will
dann kann ich die mit Home Manager für meinen Nutzer
konfigurieren und dann brauche ich auch keine
Root-Rechte dafür und das ist dann nur lokal für meinen
User.
Genau, was nämlich
NixOS quasi für deine Systemkonfiguration
ist, wo dann auch jedes Mal,
wenn du eben die Konfiguration neu brauchst,
eben Root-Rechte brauchst, weil es eben die Konfiguration
des gesamten Systems ist, ist
das gleiche ist Home Manager eben für
deine.files und für deine eben User
Applications. Das ist tatsächlich auch
etwas,
was ich irgendwie jedem, der neu einsteigt, empfehlen würde.
nutzt Home Manager und installiert damit dann auch eure Software,
weil Home Manager kann dann eben auch zum Beispiel
einfach deine SSH-Dot-Files erzeugen,
die du dann auch einfach im Nix-Expression-Language-Format konfigurierst
und das baut dir dann eben auch deine Dot-Files zusammen
und installiert die notwendige Software.
Also ich brauche Home Manager?
Home Manager brauchst du nicht,
aber das würde ich einfach jedem empfehlen.
Also ich brauche den Nix-Fackage-Manager?
Genau.
Wenn ich jetzt noch nicht auf NixOS gehen würde.
Genau. Home Manager funktioniert auch auf nicht NixOS-Distribution.
Ah. Also Home Manager hat erstmal prinzipiell nichts mit Nix zu tun.
Na, es ist für Nix geschrieben.
Aber ich kann es jetzt auch auf Ubuntu oder auf Arch.
Genau.
Und damit kannst du eben so, wie du unter NixOS deine Systemkonfiguration zusammenbaust, kannst du halt deine quasi User-Konfiguration, also die.files, zusammenbauen und eben dort auch damit dann eben auch zum Beispiel dieses deklarative Software-Management machen,
dass du eben Home Manager eine Liste angibst,
welche Programme soll ich jetzt installiert haben.
Und dann würde Home Manager hingehen
und mit dem Nix-Paket-Manager dann mir Sachen nachdenken?
Genau.
Ah, okay, krass.
Das ist alles sehr stark integriert.
Also mein Einstiegspunkt als blusiger Anfänger
könnte jetzt schon mal erstmal dieser Home Manager sein.
Da könnte ich jetzt mal meine ersten Schritte machen.
Du installierst dir auf dein Ubuntu oder Debian erstmal Nix
und dann den Home Manager.
Und dann kannst du anfangen,
eben sowohl deinen.files als eben auch die Pakete,
die du haben willst.
Und nix installieren heißt, den Paketmanager installieren.
Genau.
Okay, und dann installiere ich mir damit mein Firefox in mein Home-Verzeichnis erstmal,
weil ich dem noch keine Route-Recht gegeben habe.
Und dann habe ich aber von dem nix-Manager bereits so ein User-Local,
also in meinem Home-Verzeichnis trotzdem so eine Softlink-Baum-Hierarchie,
die mir meine Binarys dorthin linkt, damit ich die an eine,
Also damit ich bloß einen Ordner zu meinem Pfad
zusätzlich noch hinzufügen? Genau.
Ah, okay.
Es ergibt sich langsam
ein Einstiegspunkt.
Das Ganze ist dann auch
multi-userfähig. Also man kann
jetzt verschiedene
Nutzer hat auf dem System, dann kann nicht wirklich jeder
seine eigenen Programme installieren.
Ohne dass sie sich dann ins Gehege kommen.
Das ist halt auch nochmal ein anderer Vorteil.
Ja, was wolltest du sagen?
Also zumindest das mit den
mehreren Usern funktioniert vor allem dann,
wenn du auch nichts mit
Root-Rechten installiert hast, weil dann läuft einfach
so ein Demon im Hintergrund und jeder
Nutzer kann dann auch eben ohne Root-Rechte
eben die eigenen Programme installieren, weil
sie eben nur bei diesem Nutzer jeweils selbst auftauchen
und eben ja auch dieser ganze
Prozess eben einigermaßen gesandboxed ist.
Ziemlich geil.
So, jetzt schaue ich mal ganz kurz auf die Uhr.
Haben wir noch
andere Nix-Themen, die wir
platzieren wollen oder wollen wir
langsam in den etwas lockereren Teil
übergehen? Vielleicht können wir einfach noch so
ein paar praktische Tools, die wir jetzt auch
schon meistens irgendwie schon angesprochen
haben, nochmal explizit ansprechend
dann in den Shownotes entsprechend verlinken.
Das wäre gut. Die so in dieses
Nix-Ökosystem eben gut rein
sich integrieren.
Und zwar wären das meiner Meinung nach einmal eben
dieser Home Manager, den wir angesprochen haben.
Den sollte man also, den kann man auf jeden Fall
schon mal, ob man Nix nimmt oder nicht.
Und dann haben wir angesprochen,
und man kann sich eben für sein Projekt
ein Environment bauen,
was man dann eben exakt für dieses Projekt benutzen will.
Da schreibt man sich eben so ein Shell.nix-File
und dort kann man dann eben auch mit diesem Standard-Tool,
was mit dem Nix-Paketmanager mitkommt, rein wechseln,
das heißt Nix Shell.
Aber dann landet man eben einfach in so einer normalen Bash,
die jetzt irgendwie auch nicht die ganzen fancy Konfigurationsoptionen hat,
die man normalerweise in seine Shell rein integriert hat.
Weil sie dein Home nicht mit reinzieht.
weil es ist einfach eine neue Bash,
die einfach mit einer minimalen Konfiguration startet.
Und dafür gibt es dann eben diese Kombination aus Deer-Enf,
was wir ja schon angesprochen hatten.
Und Deer-Enf hat entweder selbst solche Hooks,
aber heutzutage würde man eigentlich ein Programm namens Lorry verwenden.
Das baut einfach immer quasi die Konfiguration,
die du gerade brauchst
und gibt dann eben die Konfiguration an Deer-Enf weiter,
dass eben Deer-Enf dort reinwechseln kann.
vielleicht nochmal zur Wiederholung,
die Env ist eben tatsächlich einfach so ein Hook, der sich in deine Shell hängt
und wenn du in ein bestimmtes Directory
reinchangest, aktiviert
es halt ein bestimmtes Environment.
Genau, das habe ich eine Zeit lang
als Ersatz für Ruby Env
oder sowas verwendet
auf jeden Fall, dass der dann deinen Pfad
umsetzt, wenn du in einen anderen Ordner gehst und dann
sich ein anderes Python oder ein anderes Ruby
lädt und jetzt kann man sich damit quasi, wenn man
in einen bestimmten Unterordner geht, ein komplettes
anderes Subsystem
über nix laden. Genau, da kannst du dann eben auch sagen,
ja, hier, ich will jetzt dieses alte Ruby oder
dieses
neuere Ruby verwenden. Ich könnte zum Beispiel
sagen, wenn ich in diesem, ich habe mein Softwareprojekt,
was meine Web-Anwendung ist und dann habe ich da Unterordner,
wenn ich da reingehe, in den Unterordner,
dann wird zum Beispiel ein altes,
ein drei Jahre altes Firefox
geladen, weil ich meine Anwendung
dagegen noch testen können möchte.
Was natürlich immer ein bisschen schwierig ist, beispielsweise
NPM und sowas,
du musst natürlich die ganzen Module dann auch irgendwie
für NixOS paketieren, was
bei vielen Dingen schon automatisch geht.
Also es gibt diverse Tools, zum Beispiel
PyPI tun nix oder Yarn tun nix,
die einfach versuchen und es meistens
auch schaffen, also einfach
automatisch eine
Nix Build
Expression für eben
diese ganzen Programmiersprachen-Libraries
zu erzeugen, aber das ist natürlich immer noch
ein Punkt, wo der natürlich wieder
eine Abstraktion mehr ist. Das heißt,
das ist immer eine Abwägung,
du kriegst eben diese ganzen
Comfort Features von nix, aber
das ist halt eine Stelle, an der es immer noch leider kaputt gehen kann.
Aber jetzt mal tatsächlich
dieser, weil mir gerade dieser Use Case einfällt,
also zum Beispiel, du baust
eine Web-Anwendung und du möchtest
irgendwie Tests machen, wo du nicht nur gegen
Chrome, Firefox, Edge testest, sondern
auch irgendwie gegen die letzten fünf Versionen
davon, weil du schaust, ob irgendwas kaputt gegangen ist.
Es ist teilweise schwierig, diese Version
zu bekommen, aber wie ist es jetzt zum Beispiel,
könnte ich jetzt sagen, ich habe eine Konfiguration,
wo ich explizit
Chrome 61
vorwendet, da gibt es dann,
würde ich mir das dann immer aus so einem Bildcache ziehen,
wird der irgendwann, gibt es die Pakete
vielleicht irgendwann nicht mehr oder
wie ist da die Erfahrung,
was diesen Bildcache angeht,
ist der irgendwann, also
ist das Zeug immer noch eine Weile da?
Ja,
der ist ziemlich lange da,
also der wird
gesponsert von
gewissen Firmen und
ich glaube von Fastly wird das CDN betrieben
und so weiter. Also der ist ziemlich groß,
der liegt auf Amazon und
ich habe es noch nie erlebt, dass
da Dinge wieder rausgeflogen sind, also die müssen
dann schon ziemlich, ziemlich alt
sein. Ich glaube,
an einem bestimmten Punkt wurde dann wirklich
gesagt, es wird noch nie mehr gelöscht.
Also es kann sein, dass es irgendwie Revisionen
gibt von Nix-Packages, die noch nie mehr
in die Binary-Cache abgefasst
werden, aber ich glaube,
alles ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt ist
da drin vorhanden.
Und zur Not als Firma kannst du dir auch einfach selbst
deinen eigenen Binary Cache bauen,
den du dann einfach in alle Systeme reinkonfigurierst.
Und zum Beispiel, wir haben ja schon,
Mick hat ja schon erzählt, dass oftmals einfach
nichts so in den CI-Prozess von Leuten irgendwie reininjectet wird,
damit sie endlich mal nichts benutzen können.
Und es gibt auch eine ganze CI, die quasi rund um nichts und nichts ausgebaut ist.
Das ist die Hydra.
Die baut nämlich auch tatsächlich jeden Commit
im Master Branch von diesen Nix-Packages,
baut sie einmal komplett durch
und fährt dann ein paar automatisierte Tests dagegen.
Und diese Tests können schon relativ speziell werden.
Zum Beispiel so der Standard-Vorzeigetest,
den man immer erwähnt, ist so ein Test,
der drei Maschinen virtualisiert.
Das eine ist ein Server mit einem Apache.
das andere ist ein BitTorrent-Tracker
und das dritte,
es sind glaube ich sogar vier, und dann hast du noch zwei Clients,
zwei BitTorrent-Clients,
wo dann der eine irgendwie erstmal
den Torrent runterlädt, dann wird der Tracker
abgeschaltet und dann lädt der andere Client
das nur noch über
eben dieses
DHT-Lookup runter.
Und das läuft alles automatisiert
in dieser Hydra,
in dieser CI ab, bevor dann tatsächlich
dieser Stand
als geprüft
markiert und an alle Systeme ausgerollt wird.
Das heißt, als Firma kannst du dir auch einfach
deine Software eben mit
Nix verwalten,
von der Hydra durchtesten lassen und
die Hydra baut das dann ja auch und dann hast
du es ja alles schon mal gebaut und das dann als
Binary Cache benutzen. Das ist ein sehr skurriles
Beispiel.
Das testet recht viel ab.
Das ist zumindest
ein ziemlich spannender
Ansatz. Also das ist tatsächlich
mal eine Überlegung wert, ob man das nicht verwenden könnte.
Das finde ich cool.
Ja, es gibt noch was anderes.
Das Nix-Index hast ja du reingeschrieben, Mick.
Mick mal bitte.
Ja, ich habe es noch für andere kleine Tools.
Also das Nix-Index ist, wenn man jetzt irgendwie neue Programme sucht,
wenn man jetzt wissen will, wie die Nix heißen,
dann gibt es halt eben mal die Möglichkeit,
über Nix-Search über den Programmnamen das zu suchen.
Aber wenn man jetzt zum Beispiel irgendwie bloß den Dateinamen kennt,
der vielleicht im Paket vorkommen würde,
dann gibt es noch sowas, das heißt Nix-Index.
das hat halt im Prinzip
einen Suchindex über alle Dateien
die in allen Nix-Paketen irgendwie vorkommen
das ist immer ganz praktisch
auch wenn man zum Beispiel einen Bildprozess hat
und jetzt irgendeine Library fehlt
um von dem
Library-File zum Paketnamen zu kommen
das ist ganz praktisch
was anderes
für Projekte
wenn man zum Beispiel jetzt noch
Dienste zum Beispiel für sein Projekt braucht
und jetzt aber nie auf seinem
globalen System installieren will,
sondern nur
in dem
konkreten Projekt.
Es gibt sowas, das heißt NixOS Shell
und das nimmt dann halt
einfach so eine Konfigurationsdatei
wie die Nix Shell
und startet aber da eine VM,
die nur für das
aktuelle Projektverzeichnis ist und die bekommt quasi
das Projektverzeichnis, wie man das
zum Beispiel von Tools wie Becran kennt,
wird dann einfach mit in die VM mit reingemounted
und dann werden auch die Dienste, die da drin sind, mit konfiguriert,
sodass man dann zum Beispiel, was weiß ich, ich brauche jetzt einen Postgres oder so
und das ist jetzt aber nur für dieses Projekt und ich will den danach auch nicht mehr sehen,
sondern dass das dann nur quasi, solange ich die Nix-Wars-Shell offen habe,
dass dann dieser Dienst noch mit zusätzlich konfiguriert ist in seinen eigenen VM.
Cool. Dann haben wir jetzt eigentlich relativ gut abgedeckt,
was man so als Einsteiger über Nix wissen könnte und sollte.
Die ganzen Tools listen wir alle noch mit Links in den Shownotes auf.
Die könnt ihr euch jetzt durchlesen.
Ich glaube auch, das war ein ziemlich breiter Überblick.
Das war ein relativ breiter Überblick auf jeden Fall.
Vielen Dank für eure Eindrücke an dieser Stelle.
Es war sehr, sehr aufschlussreich.
Ich glaube, dann haben wir jetzt erstmal genug über nichts erzählt.
Wollen wir dann zu den GitHub Stars kommen?
Ja, ich glaube dann...
Also nochmal vielen Dank für diese Zusammenfassung über nichts.
Die Leute können jetzt alles nachlesen, die das jetzt gehört haben.
Und ich glaube, so langsam können wir uns auch abrunden.
Aber eine wichtige Kategorie haben wir in dieser Episode noch nicht behandelt.
Eigentlich haben wir überhaupt keine Kategorien behandelt.
Wir haben die ganze Zeit über nichts geredet.
Das ist eine krasse Folge heute, so thematisch konzentriert und trotzdem nichts.
Aber gut, dann kommen wir jetzt mal zur Kategorie GitHub-Stars oder Picks der Woche oder des Monats.
Also ein Pick der Folge.
Die ersten Picks dieses Jahres, 2020.
Der Dekade.
Lass uns mal nicht die Diskussion darüber anfangen,
ob jetzt eine neue Dekade angefangen hat oder nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Aber es ist doch eindeutig geklärt,
weil doch laut diesem einen Ex-KCD,
MC Hammer's Can't Touch This,
auf der CD Hits der 90er gefeatured wurde,
obwohl der 1990 rauskam.
Also ist das damit festgesetzt.
Das erste Jahrzehnt war einfach bloß neun Jahre lang.
Das ist einfach falsch.
Wenn die alten Christen nicht wussten,
dass man bei null anfängt zu zählen,
dann kann ich ihnen auch nicht helfen.
Vor allem haben wir ja damals nicht mal angefangen zu zählen.
Das wäre eher so.
Das wäre erst im Nachhinein angefangen.
Das ist ja noch ein komisches Zählsystem.
Es ist ein kompliziertes, es ist ein weites Feld.
Was für Picks könnt ihr uns denn anbieten?
Vielleicht wollen wir mal mit den Gästen anfangen.
Mick, hast du dir was rausgesucht?
Ich habe mir was rausgesucht.
Und zwar, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr den Messenger Franz kennt.
So ein Multi-Messenger.
Also einfach so ein Elektron.
Und er kriegt ja die ganzen Webseiten von den ganzen Messagern.
Messenger ist ja auch so ein Thema, das wir nie so in diesem Podcast angehen.
Und Elektron erst rechnen.
Ach so. Ah, schade.
Ja, aber man muss die ja halt trotzdem verwenden ab und zu.
Und da gibt es so einen Fork davon, der heißt Ferdi.
Und der entfernt dann die Option, dass man sich da irgendwie bei einem komischen Surfer anmelden muss.
dort seine Konfiguration
für die ganzen Dienste speichern, sondern
es ist dann einfach lokal und ja.
Finde ich gut.
Und die Konfig, die liegt nicht mehr in der Nix-Konfig mit drin?
Das ist ja...
Was? Fertif? Achso, ja.
Das liegt dann nicht mehr in der Nix-Konfig mit drin.
Nee, das ist dann immer prob.
Also Ferdinand,
weil nach Franz kommt Ferdinand.
Frant Ferdinand.
Ja, genau.
Wahrscheinlich Deutsche oder so.
Oder? Keine Ahnung.
Ich dachte immer,
der Witz, also der Name
Franz kommt so, weil man das im Englischen
so Franz ausspricht, so wie
Franz. Aber das Logo davon ist, glaube ich,
auch so eine halbe Lederhose oder so gewesen.
Also das war auf jeden Fall
deutsch angehaucht.
Wenn der Name Franz ist und da jemand
eine Lederhose dran macht, dann muss ich garantiert ein Amerikaner
gewesen sein.
Also Ferdi ist wie Franz, nur ohne
Backend-Service quasi.
Ohne Subscription-Model.
Also Prinzip, die haben einfach den
Franz, was ja mittlerweile Open Source ist,
haben die einfach genommen und da die Sachen
rausgepatcht, dass man da mit dem
Server von Franz reden muss.
Cool, was hast du da alles drin auf?
Was habe ich da drin auf?
Ich habe das Diskurs von
NixOS, ich habe den
Riot-Chatline, ich habe
Twitter-Push-Over,
was meine Notification
Software-Monitoring, sowas schickt.
prima, IRC,
Web-Client, WhatsApp,
Facebook-Messenger, alles mögliche.
Ja, es ist weg.
Also dann nur noch eine Elektron-App.
Das ist eine schlechte Sache, ist das alles auf Elektron-Base.
Ich habe dann bloß noch eine Elektron-App,
das ist halt der Vorteil, dass dann halt
jedes Quatsch anregt eine Elektron-App.
Da wird das
Evilness, wird dann halt auf einmal
quasi, es hat nur einmal einen Schmerz.
Das denkst du zumindest.
Am Ende ist das wie Slack in Anfangszeiten
und für jede Instanz von jedem Chat-Client läuft
eine eigene Elektronistanz im Hintergrund.
Ja, ja.
Nee, ich habe das gebaut,
dass man nicht mittlerweile auch einfach...
Natürlich.
Aber könnte man da nicht auch einfach
einen Browser mit einem anderen Profil starten,
der einfach 35 Tabs aufmacht?
Ist ja quasi genau das.
Nein, und zwar der Vorteil...
Notifications oder so.
Ja genau,
es wird halt, diese ganzen Notifications
werden halt alle vereinigt,
einheitlich und
die Tabs, die sind dann halt immer an einer
fixen Stelle, also dann muss man
irgendwie kümmern, dass irgendwie die Tabs hin und her geschoben
wird und wenn man irgendwie viele Tabs
offen hat, dann findet man dann in seine
Chat-Tabs mehr wieder und so sind die dann halt
in der Stelle und ich kann halt mit dem
Shortcard, kann ich halt zum bestimmten Chat-Client
da springen und dann geht er halt auf
das ist
funktioniert für mich besser und vor allem, wenn man auf links
in Messenger draufklickt, dann gehen die halt dann
nie in diesen
Teil, in diesen Ferdie auf, sondern die werden dann halt
im normalen Browser geöffnet.
Das stimmt, das ist cool.
Und das bundelt jetzt
aber dann tatsächlich doch die offiziellen Clients
irgendwie einfach zusammen in einem Interface, oder?
Die Webseiten zum Beispiel.
Oder hat das tatsächlich doch
die eigene Client-Implementierung?
Es
produziert nur die
Webseiten von den einzelnen
die aber eigentlich in der Regelverhalten sind.
Also alles bis auf Signal, das konnte ich da eigentlich irgendwie unterbringen.
Okay, das ist dann tatsächlich ein bisschen schade, weil ich habe mich ja gar nicht richtig vorgestellt.
Eins meiner Charakteristika ist, dass ich irgendwie gerne obskure Systeme verwende, wie zum Beispiel NixOS.
Aber ich benutze eben auch zum Beispiel auf dem Smartphone kein Android oder so, sondern ein SafeOS.
Und da hat man natürlich ganz oft damit zu kämpfen, dass es irgendwie dafür keine offiziellen Clients gibt.
Und zum Beispiel WhatsApp gab es irgendwann mal,
also abgesehen davon, dass man es eh nicht benutzen will,
aber gab es irgendwie vor Jahren mal
einen komplett from scratch geschriebenen Third-Party-Client,
aber der wurde dann eben halt weggeblockt von WhatsApp.
Und schade, dann ist das leider Ferdie doch nicht so interessant,
sondern eher einfach nur ein Convenience-Fedure.
Wir nutzen ja eh bald alle Matrix
und dann dementsprechend noch die Bridges
für die komischen alten Dinge, die man noch anbinden muss.
Und dann läuft das ja, dann kannst du deinen Client deiner Wahl nutzen,
den einen Client.
Witzigerweise hat ein Kollege bei mir im Büro auch ein Sailfish OS-Telefon.
Er hat sich ja als Snicks installiert, um dann Zickle-Vessager wieder zu installieren.
Ah, wie cool.
Okay, ich glaube, du musst...
Also es läuft auch auf dem Telefon.
Der Kreis schließt sich.
Sehr gut.
Also das war jetzt Ferdi.
Dann Herr Schmittler auch, bitte
Ihren Pick. Genau.
Ich möchte hier eine Font
vorstellen. Und zwar
ist es, ich bin wahrscheinlich
ein bisschen komisch, aber
ich mag Serifen-Fonts.
Und deshalb habe ich mir irgendwann mal, als ich nicht
einschlafen konnte, gedacht,
so eine Monospace-Font mit Serifen
wäre doch schön. Und dann habe ich
auch tatsächlich eine gefunden.
Und diese Font heißt Iosefka.
Und war auch schönerweise schon
in Nixos paketiert.
Und um den Kreis jetzt aber wieder zu schließen,
dummerweise,
war diese Font eben,
diese Font gibt es in verschiedenen Geschmacksrichtungen quasi,
in verschiedenen Varianten.
Die gibt es einmal ohne Serifen,
sie gibt es auch mit Serifen und dann gibt es sie auch noch
mit diesen Ligaturen, dass irgendwie
beispielsweise ein Ausrufezeichen
ist gleich oder
ist auch ungleich wird.
Und aber
wenn ich die halt nicht in einem Editor
verwenden soll, in meiner Shell,
finde ich solche
Ligaturen dann irgendwie doch ein bisschen zu verwirrend.
Deshalb wollte ich eben die Variante haben,
mit Serifen, ohne Ligaturen.
Und dann musste ich auch einfach nur
zwei Parameter in der Nix-Bild-Expression
ändern. Dummerweise sorgt das aber
dafür, dass ich die Font jetzt selbst bauen muss.
Diese Font wird mit Node.js
gebaut. Das heißt einfach,
dass alle meine Cores, wenn diese
Font gebaut wird, für fünf bis zehn Minuten auf 100%
sind. Zehn Minuten, weil du dein Node.js
noch neu bauen musst. Aber dafür
habe ich einfach eine sehr schöne
Font mit sehr schönen Slap-Serifen
als Monospace-Font in meinem Terminal.
Was sind denn Slap-Serifen?
Diese serifenlose Variante davon finde ich,
außer dass sie ein bisschen kondensed ist, ja ganz ansehnlich.
Aber du magst wirklich sehr viele Font im Editor.
Vor allem sind das
vielleicht so in die Font-Terminologie, so Slap-Serifen
sind halt nicht solche hässlichen,
abgestufen, abgerundeten Serifen, wie man sie aus
Times in Roman kennt, sondern einfach so
Strich oder nicht Strich.
Also an so einem I ist dann halt auch ein Strich unten dran
und sowas, aber der ist halt an allen Stellen gleich dick.
Und ich finde,
Genau, ich mag persönlich
die Variante mit den Serifen sehr, sehr gerne.
Ist die schon bei Coding-Fonts aufgelistet?
Gute Frage, keine Ahnung.
Sehr schön.
Und genau, da ich ja generell
Serifen mag, zum Beispiel auch noch
die Font, die ich auf meinem
E-Book-Reader als Default-Font eingestellt
habe, die hat den wunderschönen Namen
Vollkorn. Das ist echt ein schicker Name.
Aber auf dem Re-Reader,
wo man Inhalte konsumiert, wie Bücher
oder längere Texte, da sind Serifen-Fonts
echt klasse. Aber im Editor,
Also bei Vollkorn muss ich dazu sagen,
Vollkorn ist meine Haus- und Hofschrift.
Die benutze ich schon
ziemlich lange auf meiner Webseite als Titel
und eigentlich auch
jedes Mal, wenn ich einen Vortrag halte,
stelle ich die Überschriften
auf Vollkorn.
Das ist quasi meine Markenschrift.
Ich bin halt damals auf Vollkorn gekommen.
Daran habe ich halt irgendwie unsere Abizeitung mal
gesetzt, damals.
Also wenn ihr auf hoodie.de geht,
Wenn ihr auf foodie.de
gegangen wärt, als es gerade noch ging,
vielleicht demnächst, dann seht ihr da, meine Überschrift ist
vollkorn. Jetzt gerade nicht.
Requirements so lang.
Cool.
Kejan.
Mach ich mal weiter. Ich habe diesmal
kein GitHub-Star, sondern die schicke
Webseite npmdrinkinggame.party
Was?
Das ist npmdrinkinggame. The rules are simple.
You write an english word in the input and if it exists
in npm, you must drink.
Und es ist echt schwer, wenn du wirklich
englische Inputwörter nimmst, da was zu finden,
was noch nicht besetzt ist.
Wenn ich gerade unseren Namen mal eingebe, hat tatsächlich nur MIG verloren,
weil MIG als NPM-Package schon existiert.
Aber sowohl IKEA und Hendrik als auch Schmidt-Lauch sind
noch nicht belegt. Wundert mich aber tatsächlich.
Hoodie ist aber, das kannst du natürlich verloren.
Das ist Onode Exists Generic Backend
with a Client API for Offline-First Applications.
Das klingt auch so richtig schön nach NPM.
Was ist MIG?
MIG ist ein Simple Stream Wrapper
for A-Record.
Eigentlich wäre es jetzt witzig,
rückwärts zu raten.
Ich gebe einen Begriff ein
und dann sagt es mir, oh, das ist ein
Happy Plugin for taking a process dump
on on-court exceptions.
Ihr müsst jetzt raten, wie das Ding heißt.
Keine Ahnung.
Wahrscheinlich Franz.
Nee, Poop.
Was?
Es gibt ein Paket, das heißt Poop
und es macht irgendwas mit Dumps.
Das passt auf jeden Fall ganz gut.
Cool, das zeige ich mal auf Arbeit.
Ach so, ansonsten möchte ich noch
einen alten Pick von mir zurücknehmen.
Beziehungsweise ein Thema, ein Projekt, über das wir mal gesprochen
haben, nämlich war das Snips.
Dieses tolle... Snitch AI?
Genau, diese Plattform für
Self-Hosted
Home Assistance, die aber auch unter anderem
den Teil des Stacks, den ich immer
für ein paar Projekte benutzt habe, war
Intent Parsing für
Text-Input. Das fand ich immer sehr, sehr
toll. Da habe ich auch letztens auf einem Hackathon hier in Dresden
ein tolles Projekt mitgebaut.
Problem ist, die wurden jetzt gerade von Sonos
gekauft. Oh, Snips is excited to join
Und schalten zum Zeitpunkt der Aufnahme in fünf Tagen ihre Plattform ab und jetzt ist alles kacke.
Und ich mochte die wirklich sehr.
Jetzt ist alles closed source oder was?
Die haben alles auf GitHub gehabt.
Ich weiß nicht, ob sie das löschen.
Das haben sie, glaube ich, noch nicht so gut kommuniziert gehabt.
Das heißt, die schalten ihre Plattform ab.
Ich dachte, das Geile bei Snips war, dass man es lokal alles macht.
Ja, ja.
Also die hatten aber auch ein nettes Interface auf der Webseite, wo du deine Assistenten antrainieren konntest.
Und das kannst du zwar auch lokal mit deren Tools machen,
und da weiß ich halt noch nicht,
inwiefern die weiter existieren.
Das heißt, wir sollten das möglichst schnell forken?
Idealerweise das, oder wenn man es nicht maintainen möchte,
halt sich wirklich mal hinsetzen und schauen,
wie man sowas selber macht.
Das werde ich mir wohl demnächst mal geben.
Na dann viel Spaß, ich freue mich schon
auf deinen Kilian ML basierten Home Assistant.
Ich habe kein Interesse daran,
den Home Assistant zu betreiben.
Ich habe mehr Interesse daran,
dieses Intent-Parsing umzusetzen.
Also ich möchte irgendwann einen komplett Open-Source,
selbst zusammenbaubaren, offline laufenden Home Assistant haben.
Es gibt ja schon etliche Projekte, die sowas angehen. Dieses
Mycroft-Dings,
dem ich sagen kann, Mycroft,
schaltet meine Mikrowelle aus?
Ist das eine Referenz, die ich nicht
verstehe? Nein, aber ich meine, dass ich mit dem
per Sprache
... Achso, ja, wo Sprachbasiert ist, Home Assistant auf
Raspi-Basis, komplett auf dem
Device. Ah, cool, dann bin ich wohl einfach ein bisschen
ins Hintertreffen geraten, was das angeht.
Tja, schade, Snips. War schön mit euch.
Ich glaube, die Leute habe ich sogar in
Paris persönlich kennengelernt
und mich kurz mit denen unterhalten.
Das ist ja in Rust gebaut, das ganze Zeug.
Zum Teil, ja.
Auf dem Rust-Fest in Paris fahren,
haben die auch Teil von den Impul Days gehostet.
Aber ich meine, das ist schön.
Ich meine, wer möchte nicht von Sonos gekauft werden?
Das ist schon ganz praktisch.
Von Sonos gekauft werden ist ja irgendwie generell,
also Sonos schaltet, glaube ich, generell gerne mal Dinge ab.
Jetzt ging ja gerade irgendwie rum,
dass irgendwie alle, ich glaube, vor 2011 gekauften Geräte
jetzt keine Updates mehr kriegen.
solange du nur irgendwie eins davon rumzustehen hast,
können auch alle anderen
Geräte in deinem Haus nicht mehr geupdatet werden.
Das ist so eine Bridge, von denen du auf eine
neuer Firmware irgendwann ziehen musst
und die unterstützt irgendwie die alten Dinge nicht mehr
und dann hast du Probleme.
Sonos waren sowieso die, die mal
irgendwie den Move gefahren haben vor ein paar Jahren.
Entweder akzeptierst du jetzt unsere massiv
stark geänderten Terms of Services oder
du kannst halt deine teure Hardware nicht mehr benutzen.
Haben die nicht auch Alexa direkt mit
integriert oder so? Keine Ahnung.
Aber ja, super.
Also es ist das ähnliches Hardware-Plattform.
Okay, kommen wir wieder zu positiven Themen.
Mehr Picks.
Mehr Picks, bin ich jetzt dran?
Ja.
Oh, also, ich bin ja immer sehr einfallslos.
Ich habe ein Rust-Projekt.
Und zwar bin ich gerade dabei, einen kleinen Workshop vorzubereiten,
den ich bei mir auf Arbeit halten werde
und habe mich mal ein bisschen umgeguckt,
wo man so Lernmaterial herbekommt
und habe ein bisschen in meinem Twitter-Umfeld herumgefragt
und einen sehr guten Input bekommen.
Es gibt nämlich das Rust-Bridge-Projekt.
Rust-Bridge ist quasi die Rust-Version von einem Projekt,
was Ruby Bridge heißt.
Und das ist einfach eine Lernplattform für die Programmiersprache.
Und die haben eine wunderschöne Einführungsfolien-Deck,
was ich direkt mal für die erste Stunde meines Workshops verwenden werde,
um die ganzen Grundlagen der Sprache zu erklären.
Das ist ja schon gemacht.
Und was ich aber eigentlich als Pick referenzieren wollte,
ist Rustlings.
Rustling ist ein Set von Übungen,
das man einfach ausführen kann.
Und das fängt einfach der Reihe nach an,
da gibt es einen Befehl, der heißt Rustling Watch.
Und da fängt dann einfach an,
das erste Example nach dem zweiten, nach dem dritten zu kompilieren
und dir dann im Editor aufzumachen.
Und du musst die Compiler-Fehler fixen
und dich dann von Übung zu Übung durcharbeiten.
Das ist eigentlich ein ziemlich schönes Ding
für Leute, die diese Sprache von
Null an lernen wollen,
um so klein anzufangen. Das führt dann
wirklich schön durch und das ist so gerade
für denjenigen, der den Workshop da macht, sehr praktisch,
weil du
den Leuten einfach sagen kannst, hier führt mal das aus
und dann klickt euch mal durch und dann schauen wir mal,
wie wir weiterkommen. Das GitHub-Report zu Rustlings
hat übrigens ein sehr tolles GIF
mit der Readme eingebettet von dem Typen,
der einer Krabbe so
oder von einem Vastation
so süß auf den Kopf fettet.
Ist das Jacques Cousteau?
Okay.
Jacques Cousteau?
Ist er das?
Keine Ahnung.
Der Tiefseetaurer, der die ganzen
Unterwasserdokumentationen in den 80ern
oder 70ern gemacht hat.
Ich habe ihn nicht gelebt.
Ich auch nicht, aber gut, okay.
Der hat halt meistens eher die Fische gefilmt
und nicht sich selbst.
Ich glaube, diese rote Mütze
erkenne ich relativ gut.
Aber okay, also das war jetzt so,
weil ich auch gefragt wurde, gibt es diesen Workshop
irgendwann mal öffentlich, wahrscheinlich nicht,
aber wer bei Null anfangen möchte und Rust lernen
möchte, Rust Links.
Das ist ein schönes Projekt.
Haben wir noch Sachen?
Ja, vielleicht nochmal
was, was so nix ist, und zwar,
wenn man dann anfängt, irgendwann mehr und mehr
Maschinen zu vernixen, nicht bloß den eigenen
Laptop, sondern irgendwie aufs Server oder
Raspberry Pi oder was auch immer,
dann will man das vielleicht
jedes Mal auf diese ganzen Maschinen einloggen
und das dann die Konfigurationen
da von
Hand dort anzupassen und dann den
Bildkommando auszuführen, sondern man will das vielleicht dann einfach
alles lokal, alle Konfigurationen
von allen Systemen in einem Repository haben
und dann auch unter anderem
dann zum Beispiel Module oder
Konfigurationen zwischen verschiedenen Services
oder von verschiedenen Maschinen einfach
zu teilen oder auch mit verschiedenen anderen Leuten
an Projekten zu arbeiten
und dann gibt es sowas, das heißt
Cops
Das wird von Leuten aus Stuttgart entwickelt.
Das ist einfach nur so ein Stück Nix-Konfiguration,
die man da angibt und dann baut man sich durch
und dann generiert die Ihnen so einen Befehl,
der dann die lokale Konfiguration, die man hat,
auf seinem Rechner auf den Server hochlädt.
Und dann, wenn man zum Beispiel auch irgendwelche Passwörter hat,
die kann man zum Beispiel dann mit Pass,
diesem Kommandozeilen-Programm,
Kommandozeilen-Passwort-Manager verwalten
und kann man dann auch mit seinem Kit raus hier reinpacken.
Die werden dann auch mit hochgeladen auf den Server und in den Packt.
Dann wird die ganze Systemkonversion
durchgebaut und man muss sich halt nicht auf diese
ganzen Maschinen einloggen, sondern kann das dann
schön von seinem Laptop aus
schreiben und umsetzen.
Und das ist...
Nein, es macht eigentlich nicht viel,
aber es
funktioniert sehr gut.
Genau,
Kraus benutze ich auch.
Das ist halt besonders gut
geeignet dafür, wenn du irgendwie
nur eine kleine Anzahl von Maschinen hast.
Das ist halt eins von
mindestens vier Deployment-Tools für NixOS.
Aber da hat halt
jedes seinen eigenen Fokus und ja,
kann ich auch empfehlen.
Ja, ist fast ein bisschen schade, dass es da mehrere
gibt. Na, eigentlich nicht.
Dann würde ich das fast nur ganz, ganz kurz mal aufmachen.
Und zwar unterscheiden die
sich vor allem dadurch, ob sie Push-Based
oder Pull-Based sind. Also
Push-Based sind
beispielsweise Nix-Ops, das ist so das
Erste, was da war. Das baut
Das kann auch beispielsweise
DNS 3VM und sowas gleich fertig
einrichten mit Partitionierung
und sowas und sie auch überhaupt
erst anwerfen.
Und das
baut halt die sämtliche
Software sogar lokal bei dir und
kopiert dann die gebaute Software da hoch.
Grobs wiederum
ist halt ein bisschen simpler. Das
führt halt einfach Remote-SSH-Kommandos aus,
nachdem es ein paar Dinge dahin
kopiert hat. Und das baut dann eben
die Software, die Software wird dann
auf dem Server selbst gebaut.
Und dann gibt's noch Hale,
das ist Pull-Based, da ist eben die Idee,
das macht zum Beispiel das...
Hängt das mit Hydra zusammen?
Genau, das kann man sehr gut mit Hydra zusammen
verwenden.
Da baust du nämlich
deine gesamte Systemkonfiguration
in der Hydra durch.
Und wenn alle Tests passen,
dann pullt einfach
Hale periodisch
eben den aktuellen Stand,
der von der Hydra jetzt freigegeben
wurde und deployt
ihn eben lokal. Das ist eben, wenn du
in einem großen Unternehmen bist, wo
mehrere Leute, wo du
ein Repo quasi als
Source of Truth für die
Infrastruktur hast, auf das
aber mehrere Leute Zugriff haben, beziehungsweise wo
dann irgendwie auch mit Pull-Request und sowas arbeitest,
dass dann
nicht jeder irgendwie das pushen
können muss, sondern dass einfach die Maschinen regelmäßig
pollen, ob es jetzt ein Neukonfig gibt.
Krass, cool.
Sehr schön, kurz und knapp, das Fass auf und gleich wieder zugemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Gut, ich glaube...
Also ich hatte hier noch einen Pick.
Du hast noch einen Pick.
Genau.
Und zwar bin ich auch ein großer Freund des Selbsthostens und der Dezentralisierung.
Die Kategorie heißt jetzt zwar GitHub-Stars der Woche, aber...
Die Kategorie heißt Picks.
Ja.
Oder unbenannt.
Genau, also ich würde es nicht auch lieber Picks umbenennen.
Die Kategorie formerly known as GitHub-Star der Woche.
Ich würde sie nämlich lieber Pix nennen, weil manche Dinge jetzt ja auch nicht unbedingt auf GitHub liegen, was ja auch gar nicht mal so schlecht ist.
Das Problem ist aber, es ist natürlich immer noch sehr, sehr komfortabel, wenn du auf GitHub bist, weil dort einfach fast jeder seinen Account hat und du dann einfach es ganz einfach für Leute machst, dass sie eine Issue aufmachen, dass sie eine PR aufmachen.
Und es gibt aber ein Projekt, das sich so ähnlich wie eben das Fediverse für Mastodon und Play Romans und sowas schon quasi eine Alternative für Twitter bietet, dass eben auch diese ganzen selbst gehosteten dezentralen Git-Instanzen wie ein GitLab oder ein Gitti eben miteinander auch irgendwie föderieren können.
Und das ist der Standard ForgeFed, der eben gerade noch entwickelt wird und der auch gerade irgendwie einen Förderungstopf bekommen hat.
Also ForgeFed ist sowas wie Mastodon für Git.
Genau, ForgeFed passt tatsächlich dieses Activity-Pub-Protokoll,
was irgendwie auch hinter Mastodon sowas steckt,
definiert es nochmal genauer für den Anwendungsfall,
dass man eben Pull-Requests stellen möchte,
Issues aufmachen möchte und diskutieren kann
über GitLab und Gitti-Instanzgrenzen hinaus.
Wie schlecht.
Die haben gerade irgendwie einen Fördertopf bekommen
und da passiert dann hoffentlich was.
Das heißt, ich könnte auf meiner Git-Fat-Fat-Instanz Tickets auf deinem Repo auf einem anderen Dings aufmachen.
Genau. Und vor allem auch, dass du dir dort einen Account erstellen musst,
weil einfach der Account auf deiner Instanz dann einfach mit dem da drüben föderiert.
Das ist immer das Schöne. Git ist ja von Haus aus schön sauber dezentralisiert,
aber halt nur der Akt des Klonens.
Und naja, das war es quasi meistens schon, weil du halt da keinen Account hast, wo das Zeug hinkommt.
Git ist, ist föderalisiert, aber nicht GitHub.
Genau.
du stehst halt entweder einen Patch hin oder per Mail
oder du erstellst dir einen Account
und kannst ein PR aufmachen und Issues.
Aber das ist halt alles immer ein bisschen
hakelig. Ja, der eigentliche Pull-Request
kommt ja daher, dass du bei dir
irgendwie über HTTP das Repo nochmals
geforkt, gehostet hast und
dem Haupt-Maintainer gebeten hast, von dir
zu pullen. Das ist halt, die
Terminologie ist ein bisschen kaputt gegangen, dann als wir mit
GitHub als zentralen Ort angefangen haben.
Deswegen nennst du GitLab auch
sinnigerweise dann Merge-Request.
Aber cool, nicht schlecht. Also
ich muss jetzt gerade auch an dieses eine Projekt denken,
was dir erlaubt hat, sowas wie Tickets
und Dokumentationen,
ich glaube, es waren vornehmlich
Tickets,
im Git selber mit einzuchecken, so als
extra Branch, aber das ist hier
nochmal was komplett anderes. Und das Schöne
dadurch, dass es eben auch auf Activity Pub
basiert, ist zumindest auch eins der Ziele und das
ist ja auch möglich, dass du dich dann auch
beispielsweise per Mastodon einfach
auf ein Projekt subscriben kannst oder auf ein Issue subscriben
kannst und das dann auch in deiner Timeline aufbetaucht.
Also es ist tatsächlich mit Mastodon kompatibel.
Implementiert ist davon noch nicht wirklich so viel.
Also es gab jetzt irgendwie erstmal quasi Spezifikationsdiskussionen.
Aber genau, dieses Fediverse, was alles mit ActivityPub spielt,
spielt ja relativ gut zusammen.
Zum Beispiel, es gibt ja auch so Plattformen wie Peertube,
wo du eben Videos posten kannst.
Ist das auch ActivityPub?
Genau, das ist auch ActivityPub.
Und wenn du so einem Peertube-Channel folgst
und jemand ein neues Video postet,
taucht das in deiner Mastodon-Timeline auf,
Wenn du auf diesen Eintrag
bei Mastodon replyst, landet
der Reply auf Peertube als Kommentar unter dem Video.
Das nutze ich sehr aktiv,
aber hin und wieder sehr gerne.
Ich sehe, ich muss mich damit mehr beschäftigen.
Ich wollte das eigentlich mal in einer
Folge vor über
einem Jahr oder vor zwei Jahren
in Akronomisier mal ansprechen und dann haben wir kurz
gedacht, vielleicht ist doch bloß Quatsch und dann haben wir es sofort
für tot erklärt.
Das war Peak
Web 3.0, Akronomisierbar
15 war das, sorry,
jetzt kannst du die da.
Wird das dann auch, also ich habe
sicher auch schon irgendwie Plattformen
bereit erklärt, das zu implementieren, also
irgendwas wie Gox oder Gitti oder so,
also wer ist da jetzt schon im Boot?
Also das muss ich jetzt
noch zeigen, also GitLab hat zum Beispiel
prinzipielles Interesse bekundet
und auch Gitti,
die haben sich, glaube ich, in der Standardisierung jetzt
aber doch erstmal ein bisschen mehr zurückgehalten,
aber dadurch, dass es eben jetzt ein NLNet
für das Projekt gibt,
können eben auch
potenziell Leute dafür bezahlt werden,
dass sie es in existierende Software implementieren.
Und also es gibt jetzt eben
ein neu angefangenes Hesskip-Projekt,
was irgendwie so quasi als
Prototyping-Plattform dafür dient,
von einem, der irgendwie mit am aktivsten
in dieser Spezifikation war.
Aber genau,
also wenn Leute darauf Lust haben,
das irgendwie in Go,
in GitI zu implementieren oder eben in,
ich glaube,
GitLab benutzt der Ruby oder so,
da irgendwie reinzuwerfen können,
die sich da dann auch jetzt mal irgendwie
um Mittel aus diesem Fördertopf
bewerben. Dieses Not-a-Bug,
auf dem wir das hier gerade sehen, ist das
was Eigenes? Das ist ein Gox.
Weil das gibt sich ja
überhaupt keine Blöße, genauso auszusehen wie
GitHub. Gox
war explizit ja ein GitHub-Klon.
Gox war irgendwann mal so ein bisschen
in Limbo, ob das weiter mitnehmen will oder nicht. Dann gab es
Gitti als Fog davon. Genau.
Und ich nutze Gitti auch sehr gerne.
ist jetzt ein Fork davon, oder was? Genau, Notabuck
ist einfach ein Gitti-Fork. Ist ein Gox-Fork,
steht.
Ist die Powell-By-Gox sogar auf der Startseite.
Krass.
Das ist doch gar kein Fork, sondern
Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was
sie da genau geforkt haben, aber irgendwas haben sie geforkt.
Gefahren.
Wollen wir es dann langsam zusammenrollen?
Ja.
Ich hätte entweder noch einen Pick, oder den lasse ich auch.
So, du hast jetzt
eine Chance, noch einen Pick. Genau.
Nur ganz kurz, wer mal irgendwie in theoretischer Informatik ganz viel von irgendwelchen Parsern und sowas gehört hatte, ich hatte dann mal den Use Case, dass ich tatsächlich dann auch mal was parsen sollte, was man bestimmt auch irgendwie mit Rekeksen erschlagen könnte, aber hatte ich keine Lust drauf.
Und dann habe ich erstens die PEG-Parser-Grammars gefunden, die ich glaube, ich blamiere mich jetzt wahrscheinlich total, aber ich glaube, es waren kontextsensitive Grammatiken, die man damit größtenteils ausdrücken kann.
Und ich wollte das halt in Python, wollte halt in Python was parsen und habe dann irgendwie nachdem ich drei oder vier Libraries ausprobiert habe, die Arpeggio-Library gefunden, die es einfach relativ komfortabel macht.
man schreibt sich einfach eine Parser-Grammatik,
die man entweder quasi als String
schreiben kann, so wie man es irgendwie dann auch aus der
Vorlesung kennt, oder eben auch als
Python-Objekte baumförmig zusammen
benutzen kann. Und das passt einem das dann alles
durch und man kann dann irgendwie
einen Tree-Walker darüber werfen
und tut, funktioniert.
Crash weniger als die anderen Alternativen.
Diese Pack-Syntax
wird vornehmlich dafür verwendet,
um Code-Generatoren damit zu füttern.
Das erzeugt dir dann Python-Code daraus.
Genau. Cool. Hast du das mal
andere, also ist die
Syntax
standardisiert
genug? Ich glaube, sie weicht in
einem Punkt davon ab, das ist jetzt auch schon wieder
zwei Jahre her bei mir, dummerweise.
Also ich glaube,
man sollte sich auf jeden Fall
wie immer die Dokumentation durchlesen, aber
ich glaube, bis auf einen kleinen Edge Case
tut es.
Cool. Ich habe ja
auch hin und wieder mal einen Parser
geschrieben und mich dann an
sowas wie NOM rangewagt,
was eine Hassliebe ist.
Man kann natürlich auch komplett manuell
man kann natürlich auch
eine manuell-Parser schreiben, aber
mit Pack habe ich auch hin und wieder mal
geliebäugelt, was mich ein bisschen abgeschreckt hat,
dass es halt eine komplett neue eigene Sprache ist,
die dann was abbildet. Aber ich sehe gerade,
dass es auch die Basis von zwei Rust-Code-Generatoren
ist. Also es scheint,
deswegen würde mich mal interessieren, ob man das, was du
da für, das, was du gemacht hast, einfach
nehmen kann und entweder in
Pack oder in Pest reinschmeißen kann
und damit dann Rust-Codes.
Leute, das ist ein Name.
Sorry, dass ich wieder das Thema auf meiner Programmiersprache
gehalten habe.
Cool, was hast du damit gepostet?
Das war tatsächlich ein
Projekt für die Uni, wo wir
irgendwie eine Problemspezifikation bekommen haben
und dann irgendwie
so einen Problemlöser-Algorithmus
draufwerfen sollten. Ich habe es tatsächlich
geschafft, mich fast komplett auf die,
also wir haben es zu dritt gemacht, ich habe mich fast komplett
auf das Parsing des Inputs
konzentriert
und die Problemanalyse,
die Problemlösung, ich glaube mit Simulated Annealing
oder sowas, also so ein
probabilistischer Suchalbukerhythmus.
Ja,
den haben dann die anderen implementiert.
also, ja.
Mit Pausen kann man schon genug Zeit verbringen.
Genau, es war so, ich weiß nicht, ob es jetzt
Yuckshaving oder Bikeshading war,
aber auf jeden Fall hat es jetzt nicht unbedingt direkt
was mit dem Sinn und Zweck der Vorlesung zu tun, aber es hat Spaß gemacht.
Das ist ein Yuckshaving. Bikeshading ist das,
was wir hier machen.
Gut, an dieser Stelle
haben wir, glaube ich, auch genügend Jax rasiert
und Bikes
geschädelt.
Das würde ich nach
zweieinhalb Stunden Aufnahme fast
jetzt eine Folge nennen.
Also vielen lieben
Dank an die Zuhörer, die bis hierhin durchgehalten
haben, obwohl wir die ganze Zeit über
nichts geredet haben.
Vielen Dank
an den Herrn Schmidt-Lauch, dass du extra
vorbeigekommen bist. Vielen Dank für den
Make an der Live-Schalter, also
Grüße nach Schottland.
sag mal Bescheid, wenn du das nächste Mal wieder
in Deutschland bist und bring mir
einen Whisky mit
weil das Hochbexit
steht vor der Haustür
aber
ich habe
meine
Aufenthaltsbild
ich darf hier bleiben in den nächsten 5 Jahren
mindestens, solange ich
Das ist dann lang genug, auf jeden Fall
meinen Abschluss da zu machen.
Dann wünschen wir dir dabei
viel Erfolg. Auf jeden Fall.
An dieser Stelle würde ich dann sagen,
das war jetzt wohl
akronomisierbar Folge 37.
War gut.
Und unser hier lokal vorhandener
Gast darf den obligatorischen
Countdown machen.
Ui, die nächste Episode
in eurer Podcast-Taties beginnt in 3,
2, 1,